So, let's go.
Exzellent.
Oh, Handy muss aufgeladen werden.
Kennt ihr das auch? Sobald euer Handy-Akku unter 50% fällt, habt ihr den Eindruck, es geht die nächsten 10 Minuten aus.
Was natürlich Schwachsinn ist, weil es hält wahrscheinlich noch einen ganzen Tag, aber man denkt immer, oh, das ist aber fast leer.
Gamepad, danke für den Sub.
Ogu.
Was hältst du von den neuesten News?
Wenn die News so neu sind, dass sie die neuesten News sind, habe ich wahrscheinlich noch nichts davon mitbekommen.
Auf welche der neuesten News spielst du denn an?
Meinst du Crowdstrike oder was? So neu ist das ja auch nicht mehr.
Schon jetzt zwei Tage alt.
Machen wir mal Package-Updates.
Arch, by the way.
Moin.
Alle am Start hier schon.
So, machen wir mal Package-Updates, bis das hier alles richtig angelaufen ist.
Zack.
Package.
Wow.
Ei, ei, ei.
Das ist das halbe Internet, wo es...
Wenn man mich mal richtig tippen kann.
Halbe Internet wird runtergeladen, aber keine neuen Aure-Package-Updates.
Warum wird das halbe Internet runtergeladen?
Ja gut, weil Java dabei ist, logisch.
Es ist Chrome, Firefox und Java dabei.
Und ein Linux-Jet, dann wundert mich nicht.
Klar, es ist ja quasi legit das halbe Internet.
Aber am ganzen Internet wäre .NET noch dabei.
So ist es nur das halbe Internet.
Und Node.js.
Weil ich hatte gestern 61 Monate.
Massive.
Und immer noch kein neues Emote.
Ja, mehr gibt's nicht.
Also, oder nicht Emotes.
Wie heißt das eigentlich?
Batch.
Immer noch kein neues Batch.
Aber, dankeschön.
Massive.
Excellent.
61 Monate.
Das musst du auch erstmal auf die Reihe kriegen.
Und da fällt mir wieder ein, dass ich tatsächlich schon 61 Monate hier ab und zu am Start bin.
Kommt mir gar nicht so lange vor.
Scheint aber so zu sein, ne?
Was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen?
Naja.
Ich hatte...
Gestern...
Die einfachsten Wartungs...
Also, die einfachsten Wartungs...
Das stimmt so nicht.
Ich hatte gestern das einfachstverdienste Geld überhaupt.
Ich hatte es ja schon auf Twitter geschrieben.
Und zwar, gestern, also am Samstag,
wollten die auf der Arbeit irgendwelche Software-Update-Wartungsarbeiten machen.
Also, das hat nichts mit Crowdstrike zu tun.
Und...
Also, das war schon länger geplant.
Und ich hatte da einen Task dabei,
was im Endeffekt daraus bestand,
dass ich da so ein paar Tage,
in ein Webinterface zu gehen,
einen Ansible-Job zu starten,
und dann ab und zu mal reinzugucken.
So, also das ist...
Also, to do so fünf Minuten.
Ungefähr, würde ich sagen.
Wenn es mal reicht.
Vielleicht auch zehn mit einloggen und allem drum und dran.
Aber nicht wirklich mehr.
Sagen wir mal fünf Minuten.
Fünf Minuten, okay?
Und...
Die haben einen Plan rumgeschickt, wann es losgeht.
Und in dem Plan stand ganz klar,
8 Uhr geht es los.
Also, was habe ich gemacht?
So 7.50 Uhr oder so eingeloggt.
Ich habe geschrieben, so, bin ready, bin da.
Tut sich nichts.
War gut, die pennen vielleicht alle noch.
Wobei man halt sagen muss, tut sich nichts.
Da waren relativ viele Leute dran beteiligt.
Mindestens zehn.
Wenn nicht sogar noch mehr.
Mindestens zehn Leute.
Die haben dann auch ein bisschen mehr gemacht.
Aber ich hatte, wie gesagt, kaum was vor.
Ich denke mir so, tut sich nichts, tut sich nichts.
Was ist da los?
So, es gab so ein Team.
Teamsraum.
Ich sitze da drin.
Tut sich nichts, tut sich nichts.
Und 8.10 Uhr oder so dann
kommen die ersten Leute rein und meinen so, ja, moin, auf geht's.
Und dann meint einer so, wieso geht doch erst um 9 Uhr los?
Moment mal, wie, es geht um 9 Uhr los?
Also, hier in der Liste, was wie abgeht,
es steht eindeutig um 8 Uhr.
Ja, aber in der Teams-Termin-Einladung
stand hier um 9.
Das heißt, ihr schickt eine offizielle Planungsliste rum,
in der 8 steht,
aber in der Einladung für Teams steht da 9.
Wer soll denn das checken?
Zumal, das Witzige ist,
in meiner Teams-Einladung
stand das auch gar nicht drin.
Ich weiß nicht, welche Teams-Einladung er da gesehen hat.
Naja, gut.
Also,
was habe ich gemacht?
Ich bin einfach bis 9 Uhr vom Rechner hocken geblieben,
weil es konnte ja jederzeit losgehen.
Ich habe dann sogar die Ansprechpartner dort gefragt,
hey, sag mal, ich blick's nicht.
Geht's jetzt vor 9 oder geht's nach 9?
Aber wie ist denn das jetzt eigentlich?
Die waren dann aber auch wieder AFK.
So.
Dachte ich mir, gut, bleibst du vorm Rechner sitzen.
Wartest, ob sich irgendwie was tut, ja.
Und rechnest das als Arbeitszeit ab.
Ich meine, ich konnte ja nichts machen.
Und irgendwann, 8.40 Uhr,
als ich gerade auf dem Klo kacken gewesen bin,
schreibt 8.40 Uhr einer im Teams,
er hat einen zweiten Termin eingestellt,
ob ich in den Call kommen kann.
Er wird jetzt schon mal anfangen.
Er sagt, ja, ich bin seit kurz vor 8 da.
Aber jetzt gerade bin ich auf dem Klo.
Ja gut, dann ging es irgendwie kurz um 9 rum los.
Dann habe ich einen Ansible-Job gestartet
und bin einkaufen.
Dann habe ich einen Ansible-Job gestartet und bin einkaufen.
Habe aber quasi
ein bisschen über eine Stunde
an Zeit bekommen
und dadurch, dass es Wochenende ist, mal 2.
Also habe ich jetzt ungefähr
zweieinhalb Stunden
Arbeitszeit bekommen für 5 Minuten arbeiten
und YouTube-Videos gucken.
Die hätten ruhig
noch ein bisschen länger brauchen können.
Ich hätte auch noch ein bisschen mehr gucken können.
Ist halt dumm, ne?
Ich hätte auch kein Problem gehabt,
mich erst ab 9 vor den Rechner zu setzen,
Wenn die das gesagt hätten
Aber wenn die sagen 8
Und ich stehe schon extra auf
Und setze mich da hin
Dann
Müsst du das jetzt auch bezahlen
Das ist nicht mein Problem
Ja das stimmt
Da hast du recht
Da reicht aber eine Stunde nicht für
Und außerdem
Muss ich mich da in der passenden Stimmung zu befinden
Für YouTube Videos
Ja
Aber das war wirklich
Easiest Arbeitszeit ever
Für 5
Für
Im Prinzip
3 mal auf Next klicken
In diesem Ansible Web Interface
Und
YouTube Videos gucken
2,5 Stunden
Arbeitszeit bekommen ist easy
Da siehst du mal wie viel Geld
Durch schlechte Planung verpulvert wird
Leute ich sag euch
Management Fail
Ist viel größer
Gerade bei größeren
Läden und auch in IT
Management Fail ist viel größer
Als das was ab und zu mal durch
Technik Fails verkackt wird
Technik Fails sind immer sehr auffällig
Ja
So
Crowdstrike zum Beispiel
Und sowas
Ja oder wenn irgendwas ausfällt
Technik Fails sind immer sehr auffällig
Management Fails sind nicht so auffällig
Kosten aber unter dem Strich viel mehr Geld
In der Summe
Nein nein nein
Mit Crowdstrike hatten wir nichts zu tun
Weil
Wir benutzen Linux
Mit Linux wäre das nicht passiert
Hätte jetzt das Heise Forum geschrieben
Aber das ist in dem Fall auch so
Mit Linux wäre das nicht passiert
Und ich kenne die Diskussion
Theorie
Theoretisch könnte das ja mit Linux auch passieren
Und dazu ist meine Antwort
Ja theoretisch
Das habe ich auch einem auf Twitter geschrieben
Theoretisch kann alles passieren
Wo die Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht 0% ist
Wenn man einfach nur lang genug wartet
Passiert alles
Was die Chance hat zu passieren
Aber dass das mit Crowdstrike unter Linux passiert wäre
Wäre praktisch nicht vorgekommen
Weil
Unter Linux keiner irgendwelche komischen
Okay keine komischen
Keiner kann man nicht sagen
Es gab Leute die haben Crowdstrike auch unter Linux verwendet
Aber denen ist dann nicht mehr zu helfen
Ja aber so gut wie keiner
So gut wie keiner sagen wir mal
So gut wie keiner verwendet irgendwelche komischen
Third Party Kernel Module
Die sich hot reloaden updaten können
Im laufenden Betrieb
Und dadurch kaputt gehen
Und dazu kommt
Dass du in der Regel
Kernel Updates beziehst
Oder Package Updates beziehst
Aus dem offiziellen Repo
Das heißt das hat dann sich schon mal einer angeguckt
Was ja bei Crowdstrike garantiert nicht passiert ist
Sonst hätten die das gemerkt
Und ich könnte das sogar
In der Testumgebung selbst testen
Im Vorfeld
Natürlich wenn man es so macht
1 zu 1 wie man es unter Windows gemacht hat
Mit einem Third Party Modul
Was sich
Quasi
On the fly
Neu macht
Neue Logik
Wie kann man das beschreiben
Neue Programmteile runter lädt
Was nicht nur Virensignaturen sind
Sondern anscheinend auch wirklich
Binary enthält
Ausführbare Graben
Der dann Fehler enthalten kann
Ja du das kannst du unter Linux auch haben das Problem
Aber das Problem hat wahrscheinlich
Unter Linux so gut wie keiner
Außer Leute die komplett
Schmerz befreit sind und so ein Krempel unter Linux installieren
Ja ja das habe ich auch gelesen
Es gab Probleme unter Red Hat
Es gab auch Probleme unter Debian
Aber das ist halt das Ding
Du kannst theoretisch dir schon das gleiche
Fehlerbild einfangen unter Linux
Das blickst ja dankeschön für den Sub
Als unter Windows
Aber es wird halt praktisch so gut wie
So gut wie nicht passieren
Weil die Leute nicht so bescheuert sind
So was installieren
Beziehungsweise es in der Art und Weise laufen lassen
Und es war ja auch nicht
Das ist übrigens auch einer der Gründe
Warum ich immer dagegen bin
Wenn es darum geht
So ein Krempel wie Microsoft
Oder Windows Defender
Einzuführen für Linux
Es gibt es ja Windows Defender für Linux
Also weiß ich ob ihr das kennt
Oder ob ihr das wisst
Es gibt Windows Defender für Linux
Und es gibt tatsächlich ein paar Enterprise Business Leute
Die halten das für eine gute Idee
Windows Defender
Windows Defender unter Linux zu verwenden
Das heißt natürlich nicht
Windows Defender sondern das heißt
Microsoft ich glaube
Endpoint Protection
Oder irgendwie sowas
Früher hieß das
Advanced Threat Protection
ATP
Das gibt es das ist quasi Windows Defender für andere Betriebssysteme
Nicht nur aber auch
Und da bin ich komplett dagegen sowas zu installieren
Weil da hast du exakt die gleichen Probleme
Und ich hab ja sogar schon
Die gleichen Probleme erlebt unter Linux
Zum Beispiel also das ist auch so ein Ding
Das Teil hier
Das ist auch so ein Ding was wie Crowdstrike on the fly ist
Irgendwelche Updates macht
Die nicht nur Updates von Virensignaturen
Verhaltensanalyse und sonst was enthalten
Sondern auch wirklich
Agent Updates
Code Updates
Und die dann Probleme verursachen können
Also wir hatten beispielsweise von heute auf morgen
Hatten wir auf einem Mail Server damals
Mega hohe CPU Last
Keiner wusste warum
So von heute auf morgen
So es war nix
Bis dann rausgekommen ist ja das war ein Microsoft Defender Update
Da lief Microsoft Defender drauf
Weil Viren Zeug scannen
Da wollte man unbedingt Microsoft Defender Shit drauf machen
Und das war ein Microsoft Defender Update
Da wollte man unbedingt Microsoft Defender Update drauf installieren
Das war auf allen Linux Servern drauf
Bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber
Aber auf dem Mail Server ist halt aufgefallen
Weil es da viel zu scannen gab
Und dann war das Ding mega hohe CPU Last
Und was kam raus?
Ja Microsoft hat nachts halt ein Security Update eingespielt
Live auf allen Systemen
Hot fix mäßig
Und das ist auch so ein Ding was ich nicht verstehe
Warum
Ist das so
So schlecht gelöst? Auch bei Microsoft?
Auch bei CrowdStrike?
Also sprich
Ich verstehe das man sagt ey
Wenn man Viren
Wenn man Antivirus
Wenn man Antivirus hat
Mit Verhaltensanalyse
Und AI Geschiss
Und so
Ich hab ja
Ich hab mir den Kram ja auf denen ihre Homepage
Also die Homepage
Sieht
Sieht extrem ähm
Gangster Hoodie auf Hackerman Style aus
Ja
Rot
Schwarz
Und irgendwelche
Uhrenanimationen
Die sie heute aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht mehr drin haben
Gestern hatten sie dann noch
Ach das ist weil es auf Deutsch war
Da gelangt wahrscheinlich
Gestern
Da ist dann
Ah doch
Da ist die Uhr
Ja
Also im Prinzip
Ist hier
ist da ganz viel
hk
Bingo am Start
Und
Ich
Ich versteh's ja zum Teil dass man sagt ey
Wenn es denn
Angriffe gibt
Da muss man möglichst schnell
keepers
Geupdated sein dass man das alles erkennt
So das versteh ich
Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
AI, AI, alles.
Und da kann ich ja verstehen, dass man, wenn man schnell reagieren muss auf irgendwelche Sachen, dass man dann Updates braucht.
Früher haben Antiviren-Software einmal am Tag oder zweimal am Tag geupdatet.
Heute passiert das quasi etwas schneller.
So.
Das ist ja alles schön und gut.
Und ich habe im Prinzip auch nichts dagegen, dass Viren-Signaturen auch in Produktion live geupdatet werden.
Vielleicht, und das wäre vielleicht ganz sinnvoll gewesen, vielleicht hätte man das trotzdem etwas verzögert ausrollen sollen.
Also das ist ja eh ein grundsätzlicher Fails, die dabei passiert ist, dass man einfach auf den Knopf drückt und die ganze Welt bekommt das.
Wenn ihr ein Webservice macht und das gescheit, also wir reden jetzt mal von was simplem, ihr habt irgendeinen Webservice und ihr installiert dort,
dort eine neue Version, in der Regel, wenn man das gescheit macht, drückt man nicht auf.
Ich mache noch genug, auch so hier wie CrowdStrike, aber eigentlich, wenn man möchte, dass es möglichst wenig Beeinträchtigungen der End-User gibt, macht man das folgendermaßen.
Man rollt das, so wie YouTube das übrigens by the way auch macht, man rollt so ein Update nicht mit Knopfdruck für alle User aus, sondern entweder macht man das mit irgendwelchen Feature-Flags oder sowas, so wie es auf YouTube ist.
Quasi manche User bekommen...
Manche haben das und dann, manche haben die App-Funktion enabled, manche nicht.
Was aber noch viel sinnvoller ist, um so solche Basic, die gesamte Welt crasht abzufangen ist, man rollt das einfach langsam aus, ja.
Man rollt das aus, leitet 10% des Traffics um auf die neue Version, guckt, ob irgendwas kaputt geht.
Dann lässt man das mal kurz laufen, guckt sich das ein paar Minuten an, stellt fest, okay, Fehler gehen nicht großartig hoch.
Dann rollt man 50% der Leute aus und dann rollt man 100% der Leute aus.
Sowas in der Richtung, ja.
Also überhaupt kein Problem, das hätte man da auch machen können, aber anscheinend sind die halt zu, wie heißt das, zu YOLO-Programmer, keine Ahnung, wir deployen alles auf einmal.
So, und genau, und damit hättest du sowas schon mal abfangen können, aber was ich eigentlich sagen wollte, was für mich so viel grundsätzlicher so ein bisschen das Problem ist,
warum sind, also ich verstehe, dass man das schnell updaten will.
Die Systeme haben keinen Fehler zurückgemeldet, na, ich weiß nicht, ob ein geprickter Windows-Rechner nicht ein Fehler ist, ne.
Also, wisst ihr, also, weiß ich, die melden das zwar nicht zurück, die melden das zwar nicht zurück, aber du hast innerhalb der ersten Viertelstunde, hast du sehr viele verärgerte Hotline-Anrufe.
Ist doch egal, ob sich das selbst melden kann.
Die haben ja Support für die Leute, werden ja schon anrufen, wenn auf einmal ihre Rechner alle Plus-Screens bekommen.
Kannst vorausgehen.
Und mal davon abgesehen, und mal davon abgesehen, die können es einfach bei sich selber ausprobieren.
Das war ja kein Fehler, der vereinzelt auftritt, das war ein Fehler, der fast durch die Bank weg aufgetreten ist.
Wenn ich sowas bereitstelle als Unternehmen für 100.000 Installationen, da hab ich bei mir selbst doch mal irgendwelche...
Test-Environments, wo ich das im Vorfeld ausprobieren kann.
Das ist eine Sache, die ich lange vor dem Rollout eigentlich machen würde.
Also, bevor das, was ich gerade gesagt hab, zum Tragen kommt.
Ja, man rollt es für 10% der Leute aus, mal 50% für 100% der Leute.
Davor, bevor ich überhaupt auf den Deploy-Button drücke, drücke ich bei mir intern mal auf den Deploy-Button und gucke, was mit meiner Testumgebung mit 50 verschiedenen Konfigurationen passiert.
Und wenn die auch alle abkacken, dann weiß ich, ich sollte vielleicht in Produktion nicht...
Nicht auf den Deploy-Knopf drücken.
Also, es ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre das großartiges Hexenwerk, sowas zu vermeiden.
So, aber das eigentliche Architektur-mäßige Problem, was ich auch nicht ganz gecheckt hab, aber wo ich mir denke, warum ist das so?
Ich verstehe, dass man möglichst schnell Updates haben will, bei irgendwelchen Bedrohungen.
Ja, das, sagen wir mal, in der Hand von einer halben Stunde, Viertelstunde und so, das verstehe ich ja.
Aber, warum enthalten diese Updates vermischt...
Agent-Logik und Antivirus-Logik, beziehungsweise und Antivirus.
Also, normalerweise war das so, früher, ja, ich verstehe, dass man das bei sowas vielleicht nicht hundertprozentig anwenden kann.
Früher war das so, du hast eine Antiviren-Software gehabt, die hat sich täglich Signaturen geupdatet.
Die Signaturen haben aber nichts an der Antiviren-Software geändert, sondern die haben die Antiviren-Software einfach...
ähm, neuere Viren erkennen lassen.
Die Antiviren-Software ist aber gleich geblieben.
So.
Ja, ich verstehe, dass man das vielleicht nicht eins zu eins hier anwenden kann,
weil gerade wenn es um Verhaltensanalyse geht und sonst was, brauchst du vielleicht schon mal Updates für Ignisentbox oder sonst was.
Aber, warum ist das Ganze so verheiratet, dass du quasi ein großes Agent-Update auslieferst,
wo alles drin ist, inklusive Agent-Logik, wo es dann eine Null-Pointer-Exception geben kann,
die den ganzen Agents...
zum Crashen bringt.
Beziehungsweise das Kernel-Modul zum Crashen bringt, oder wie man das unter Windows nennt und dementsprechend Windows zum Crashen bringt.
Das ist das, was ich von der eigentlichen Architektur nicht ganz nachvollziehen kann.
Also, das ist so ein Teil, was man ohne Probleme aus meiner Sicht hätte vermeiden können.
Ja, und was die hier, was die hier alles für komische...
Ich meine, das Ding hier besteht ja aus, aus Reiz, aus Reiz hier.
Das hier, Threat-Craft, Acid-Craft.
AI-Native, Machine-Learning, Behavioral-AI, Custom-LLMs, Foundry, Fusion, Generative-Workflow,
EDR, ITDR, Exposure-Management, MDR, CDR, Charlotte-AI, was auch immer.
Was eine Geschwätze, Alter. Was wollt ihr überhaupt von mir?
Ja, aber so sieht das aus meiner Sicht aus.
Es wäre ein Ding, was ohne Probleme vermeidbar gewesen wäre.
Aber,
und jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt der Plot-Twist.
Jetzt kommt der Plot-Twist, und zwar...
Das ist die Aktie von CrowdStrike.
Die ist um knapp, hier ungefähr mal um knapp 20% gefallen.
So, Leute.
Was meint ihr, wer gestern Morgen CrowdStrike-Aktien gekauft hat?
Nicht viel.
Was meint ihr, wer ungefähr so hier in dem Dreh...
Äh, nicht gestern.
Nicht gestern, heute ist Sonntag.
Vorgestern, Freitag.
Wer gestern für...
Nur 500...
Also, es war nicht glatt 500 Euro irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 517, 84 oder sowas.
Ich habe CrowdStrike-Aktien gekauft.
Mehr just for fun.
Weil...
Weil ich kein Vertrauen in die IT-Welt mehr habe in dieser Richtung.
Ja, ich habe genau...
Ich habe, genau, ich habe umge...
Ich habe quasi zwei Stück gekauft, genau.
Ich habe CrowdStrike-Aktien gekauft, weil ich kein Vertrauen in die IT-Welt mehr habe.
Und zwar ich da ganz...
Und zwar ich da ganz stark davon ausgehe, dass das einfach wieder hier zurückgeht, weil die Leute sowas schnell vergessen.
Das geht denen am Arsch vorbei.
Und wenn du ein Enterprise-Business-Laden bist, der da rein investiert hat und seine Infrastruktur damit betreibt, der wird das nicht umstellen.
Das Einzige war es natürlich jetzt ziemlich...
Ja, da bin ich auch mal gespannt.
Das Einzige, was jetzt natürlich noch nach hinten losgehen könnte, ist, wenn die verklagt werden, es fuck.
Und deswegen dicht machen.
Aber mal abwarten.
Also ich habe da kein Vertrauen in die IT-Entscheider dieser Welt, wie man das so schön sagt.
Dass so ein Scheiß in Zukunft nicht mehr eingesetzt wird.
Sondern, dass das in zwei, drei Wochen wieder zurück bei 350 ist.
Ja, jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, ey Max, wenn du dir da noch so sicher bist, warum hast du nicht...
Wenn du dir da noch so sicher bist, warum hast du nicht...
Weil du gleich 50.000 Euro anstatt 500 Euro.
So sicher bin ich mir da auch nicht, ja.
Außerdem mache ich das eh immer nur mit Kohle, die ich sonst nicht brauche.
Der Rest geht in meinen Stonks-ETF und bleibt da einfach liegen.
Aber lasst uns mal gucken.
Wir gucken mal in einem Monat...
Ihr könnt mich ja dran erinnern.
Wir gucken mal in einem Monat, wie es mit...
Wie es mit...
Wie es mit CrowdStrike aussieht.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das...
Ich könnte wetten, dass ist in einem Monat wieder hier oben. Schauen wir mal. Hätten wir das Thema auch. Was sagt der Chat dazu? Ich glaube noch nicht mal, dass da irgendjemand gefeuert wird. Glaube ich nicht. Ja, nice, dass du am Start bist. Glaube ich nicht, dass da irgendjemand gefeuert wird.
Es gab ja ein paar Fake-Twitter-Poster, gell. Also, es gab ja ein paar Leute auf Twitter, die behauptet haben, sie wären der Crowdstrike-Programmierer gewesen, die das gepusht hätten. Und vor allem witzigerweise, wie die Leute da auch direkt immer drauf reingefallen sind. Der eine hat irgendein gefaktes Bild gepostet von Crowdstrike, von dem Crowdstrike-Logo, mit Sicht davor und sowas. Hat gesagt, oh, ups, ich hab aus Versehen gepusht. Die Leute haben es teilweise echt geglaubt.
So, Updates haben wir gemacht. Dann lasst uns doch mal kurz gucken, was auf Shithub diese Woche so trendet.
Okay, jetzt sag ich mal her. AI? AI? Irgendwas? Ist das Spanisch? Keine Ahnung. AI? AI? AI? Nee, nicht AI. Sag jetzt einfach zu allem AI, was ich mir nicht angucken will. AI? AI? AI? Ist es nicht wirklich? Auch nicht. AI? Haben wir uns auch schon... Ich hab absolut keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Was? Wow!
Ah, AI.
AI. Okay. Na, immerhin. Zum Glück hab ich da GPT-2 gesehen, sonst hätt ich absolut keine Ahnung gehabt, was das sein sollte.
High-IQ-Diagramm, oder?
Aber da steht GPT-2, also muss es AI sein.
Nicht AI.
Noch eine neue Editor.
Ach nee, das ist ein Editor-Framework, stimmt. Das hab ich sogar schon mal gehört.
Im Prinzip ist es eine fancy Input-Textbox.
Sick. Sick. Sick.
Max, hast du die Woche wieder am ESP gebastelt?
Ja. Ich hab sogar mal Arduino rausgeschmissen und nur ESP-IDF gemacht.
Ich hab's aber nur geschafft, mich per Wi-Fi zu verbinden. Das ist viel komplizierter.
Deswegen, ich benutze den meisten Kram relativ raw, aber für so manche Sachen ist das Arduino-Zeug nicht verkehrt, weil es viel schon gerappt hat.
Da basteln wir vielleicht auch weiter dran, weil ich hab gesehen, die haben ein mega-nices neues Feature für ihren Web-Server da drin.
In ESP-IDF 5.2 oder 5.3.
Und zwar, dass man asynchrone Requests endlich machen kann mit dem eingebauten Web-Server.
Also sprich, du kannst ein Post-Request schicken, oder ein Get-Request, ist egal.
Du kannst ein Request schicken, während der Web-Server noch was anderes macht.
Das ging die ganze Zeit bisher nicht.
Was du bisher machen konntest, ist Web-Socket antworten und sowas, Async.
Aber du konntest keine normalen HTTP-Requests asynchron verarbeiten.
Was natürlich richtig nice ist.
Das wollte ich mal ausprobieren.
Aber soweit hab ich's noch nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Ich hab's grad mal geschafft, mich per Wi-Fi zu verbinden.
AI, AI, Playstation-Emulator.
Ja, da ist ja nicht wirklich irgendwas dabei gewesen jetzt, oder?
Was macht die .NET-Welt so?
Da ist bestimmt Maui und so ein Shit wieder dabei, wo ich nicht verstehen kann, warum alles in der Welt Leute Maui verwenden.
Powertoys, okay, ja, das ist okay.
Das ist eines der einzigen Dinger, die ich mir immer hier gefallen lasse in den Trends, weil da ist sinnvolles Zeug dabei bei den Powertoys.
Ja, also was ich von...
Es gibt eigentlich nur zwei Sachen, die ich von Powertoys benutze.
Das eine ist das Remappen von Keys.
Und das andere ist die...
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob das Powertoys ist.
Diese OCR-Texterkennung auf Bildern.
Ich verstehe das gar nicht, Powertoys.
Maui-Trended.
Warum auch immer, Leute, ich verstehe es nicht.
Ich finde das so hässlich...
Ach nee, der hässlichste Falschwort.
So eklig.
Hässlich kommt ja ein bisschen auf die jeweilige Plattform.
Hässlich auch.
Aber ich finde das so eklig.
Ich verstehe nicht überhaupt, was Leute verwenden.
Leuchten wir nicht ein.
Und ich warte jedes Mal, wenn ich das hier sehe, dass Maui irgendwo trendet, auf den Blog-Post von Microsoft, dass Maui eingestellt wird.
Ja, dann lieber Avalonia.
Ohne Mist.
Bevor ich Maui verwende, verwende ich lieber Avalonia.
Avalonia macht es richtig.
Und Maui macht es falsch.
Und zwar, was macht Avalonia richtig?
Also beides sind UI-Frameworks.
Mit denen du GUIs machen kannst.
Maui benutzt die Native-Control-Elemente.
Und Avalonia malt sein UI selbst.
Und ich finde, das ist der einzig sinnvolle Ansatz.
Deswegen, wenn ich irgendwas in .NET-GUI-mäßiges machen würde, dann auf jeden Fall Avalonia und nicht Maui.
Ich weiß nicht, was das sein soll.
Ach so, Subtitle.
Vielleicht müssen wir das manchmal auch wörtlich nehmen.
Okay, zack.
IL-Spy.
Ist das auch noch?
Da fragt man sich immer...
Warum brauchst du eine Zusatz-Software und kann es das Game nicht einfach von Haus aus anbieten?
Eine Roblox-Account-Manager.
Genau, das habe ich unbedingt gebraucht jetzt.
Chat-Gil.
Ja, war jetzt nicht so viel Spannendes dabei die Woche, oder?
Es gab die Woche übrigens noch was.
Wo ich auch nicht...
Wo ich nicht ganz den Hate gecheckt habe.
Ist das so?
Ich...
Ist das wirklich so?
Ich dachte bei...
Also ich meine, nachdem es immer noch viele Cosplayer gibt und sowas, die das...
Die das cosplayen.
Kann das eigentlich nicht dead sein, ne?
Ist das so?
Das ist doch...
Da wird doch Kohle gemolken ohne Ende immer noch.
Also auch eine Sache, wo ich den Hate diese Woche nicht so ganz verstanden habe.
Ihr kennt euch da doch aus.
Ihr seid doch so die richtig nicen Go-Checker-Mans im Chat.
Oder?
Wir haben noch hier...
Wir haben noch hier jede Menge High-IQ-Go-Programmers.
Jaja, ich weiß.
Ich habe auch mal eine Genshin Impact Sponsoring gemacht.
Ich war noch nie in einer Wüste.
Hahaha.
Ja.
Es ist...
Das ist clearly dead, das Game.
Obviously.
Ja, ja.
Und ich verstehe es nicht so genau.
Also es gibt in Go jetzt, habe ich gelesen.
Es gibt in Go jetzt quasi irgendwie Go-Range-Iterator oder sowas.
Ich bin ja nicht so der große Go-Checker.
So.
Aber ich habe gelesen, dass es...
Da gibt es dazu vielleicht mal irgendwie einen gescheiten Post hier.
Das ist in Go jetzt quasi...
Da gibt es quasi die Möglichkeit, dass man für seine eigenen Structs, also für seine eigenen Typen...
Was ist das hier?
Ich sehe hier ein gescheites Beispiel.
Genau.
Dass man für seine eigenen Typen quasi einen Range-Loop verwenden kann.
Das ging bisher nicht.
Es gab bisher keine Möglichkeit, irgendwie seine eigenen Klassen so iterierbar zu machen.
So wie das beispielsweise in .NET schon ganz lange geht.
Oder wie das...
Wie das sogar...
In fucking C++ geht.
Nur dass es in C++ wieder hässlich as fuck ist.
Wo man sich denkt, was zum Teufel hat sich das C++-Gremium dabei gedacht.
Zumindest...
Aber Java geht...
Das geht in den meisten Sprachen.
So.
Es gab in Go aber bisher kein so wirklich Iterator-Interface oder Range-Interface oder sowas.
In Go gibt es aber auch die Möglichkeit, seine eigenen Typen quasi for-loop-ready zu machen.
For-each-loop-ready zu machen.
Also, da kann ich dann quasi sagen, hier, for, bla, range und das hier, items, ist quasi mein Custom-Typ.
So.
Und das ist jetzt neu in Go.
Anscheinend ab dieser Woche.
Und das Feature ist extrem kontrovers und diskutiert und die meisten finden es scheiße.
Und ich habe nicht so genau verstanden, warum es die meisten Leute scheiße finden.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das hier ein guter Blog-Post ist.
Das ist falsch.
Außer, dass das schon wieder...
Sehr hässlich aussieht, aber...
Nach was?
Chat, nach was kann ich denn jetzt suchen, wenn ich ein gescheites Beispiel finde?
Wie heißt denn das richtig?
Ne.
Range?
Range-Function, nach was muss ich denn da suchen?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Das hier ist es doch, oder?
Wir gehen einfach auf das Go-Subreddit.
Und gucken, was da so abgeht.
Range.
Ja, okay.
Preview von vor einem Jahr.
Alles klar.
New.
Hier, Iterators-Range, da ist es doch.
Okay, hier gibt es ein Beispiel für Iterators.
Da ist es doch.
Range-Iterators.
Genau.
Also sprich, das ist anscheinend jetzt ganz furchtbar schlimm.
Und ich check nicht, warum.
Ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Ich habe ein Video gesehen, da wurde sich drüber aufgeregt, warum das so kacke ist.
Und ich verstehe es nicht.
Ja, die Syntax ist ein bisschen eklig.
In dem Beispiel kommt das jetzt gar nicht so raus.
Aber wo ist das Problem?
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, genau.
Das ist natürlich auch wieder ein bisschen eklig.
Das ist Sequence und Sequence 2.
Da geht man nicht so genau weiß, was Sache ist.
Aber so genau, warum die das jetzt alle so kacke finden, habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden.
Die Syntax ist ein bisschen eklig.
Ja, das sehe ich auch so.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich finde die Go-Syntax...
...an vielen Stellen umständlich und eklig.
Ich habe den Eindruck, alles, was sie an Go zusätzlich angeflanscht haben, ist nicht richtig durchdacht.
Go war ursprünglich fast schon zu basic.
Ihr kennt ja die Standardantwort der Go-Leute und auch der Go-Entwickler auf sowas wie...
Wie sieht es mit einer Filterfunktion für Arrays aus?
Wisst ihr, was sie da drauf sagen?
Also, wenn du einen Go-Entwickler fragst oder einen Go-Maintainer, wenn du die mal fragst, was haltet ihr denn zum Beispiel...
...von einer Array-Filter-Funktion?
Was sagen die dann dazu?
Die sagen dann, nein, nein, nein, nein, das braucht man nicht.
Einfach For-Loops.
For-Loops ist die Antwort auf alles in Go.
So nach dem Motto, wie jetzt?
Filterfunktion, wie sieht es denn mit irgendwie generic...
Go.
Nein, For-Loop.
Einfach For-Loop, immer For-Loop.
Also Go steht extrem auf For-Loops.
Und die Go-Entwickler auch.
So.
Und alles, was die dann irgendwie angehören...
...angeflanscht haben danach, ist irgendwie hässlich geworden.
Also die Generic-Syntax ist irgendwie hässlich und diese Iterator-Syntax ist irgendwie hässlich.
Aber ich habe keine großartige Ahnung von Go, muss ich auch gleich dazu sagen.
Wir haben zwar im Stream ein bisschen Go gebastelt, das ist nicht so, dass ich der große Go-Checker wäre.
Aber die hätten sich einfach mal in Ruhe überlegen müssen, anstatt irgendwie das nächstbeste super hässlich da reinzubasteln.
Zumindest ist das ein sehr unbeliebtes Go-Feature.
Und das finden alle und die meisten finden das irgendwie gerade kacke.
Ich glaube sogar, dass viele Go-Entwickler einfach Einsteiger sind, denen ihre erste Programmiersprache Go war.
Sicherlich die ein oder anderen Leute, die früher vielleicht C++ gemacht haben.
Aber wisst ihr, ich glaube einmal C++, Hardcore-C++ fern immer C++.
Weil wenn du dich in C++ so weit reingedacht hast, dass du C++ halbwegs fehlerfrei...
...und ohne Zweideutigkeiten programmieren kannst, kannst du keine andere Sprache mehr programmieren.
Weil keine andere Sprache ist so scheiße und so inkonsistent und so dämlich wie C++.
Das heißt, wenn du dein Mindset, wenn du das C++-Mindset hast, fällt dir alles andere schwer.
Ja, das ist ja das, wo die Go-Entwickler sagen, ja, nehm einfach eine Vorschleife.
Wenn du Go gefragt hast, ey, ich würde gerne Array filtern, warum gibt es denn da keine Filterfunktion?
Dann haben die gesagt, ja, mach einfach eine Vorschleife.
Jetzt gibt es Generics, jetzt könntest du sowas bauen.
Allerdings baut sowas keiner richtig in Go-Generics, weil, ich weiß gar nicht genau...
...weil Go-Generics immer noch nicht richtig Generics sind oder so.
Ich habe das nicht so ganz verfolgt.
Naja, also bloated wie C++ kannst du eigentlich gar nicht sein.
Oder so bloated werden wie C++.
Das Problem, C++ ist, das ist eine ganz merkwürdige Sache, ja.
C++ ist nicht bloated im eigentlichen Sinne, sodass so viel drinnen wäre.
Also, dass du jetzt sagen könntest, ey, warum baut ihr jetzt noch einen dritten HTTP-Client ein?
Oder warum...
Ja, zum Beispiel, eine der Sachen, wo .NET bzw. C-Sharp, ich nehme das jetzt mal in einem, weil die meisten Leute verwenden .NET, das ganz normale .NET Core bzw. jetzt .NET mit C-Sharp.
Da kannst du sagen, das ist bloated, weil die irgendwie acht verschiedene Timer-Klassen haben und sowas.
Aber sowas, so ist das ja in C++ nicht.
In C++ ist die Standard-Library eigentlich gar nicht so bloated.
Da fehlt dafür das meiste, was du so haben willst.
Also, wenn du denkst, ey, mach mal einen HTTP-Request, gibt es nicht in der C++-Standard-Library.
Pass mal einen JSON-String, gibt es nicht in der C++-Standard-Library.
Ja, es gibt zigtausend Packages davon.
Die aber auch, und das ist halt das Problem, übelst kompliziert und fehleranfällig sind, weil C++ so eine Schrott-Sprache ist.
Es ist nahezu ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit.
Jetzt mal, by the way, machen wir mal wirklich ein konkretes Beispiel.
Ja, das ist wieder so ein bisschen Pseudo-Code-mäßig.
Also, wenn ihr, mal angenommen, ihr wollt in .NET.
Ja, ihr habt hier einen String, blub, gleich, so, und das ist irgendein JSON-Objekt, okay?
So, A, so.
Und ihr wollt das parsen, bzw. ihr habt einen String mit einem JSON-Objekt, so, und ihr habt hier auch, keine Ahnung, struct A, so, mit einem, oder was auch immer hier, blub.
So.
Ja, irgendwie so, keine Ahnung.
Was auch immer, so.
Und mal angenommen, ihr wollt jetzt diesen String deserialisen in das struct, so.
In C Sharp würde man das quasi ungefähr so in der Richtung machen.
Ja?
Das stimmt nicht so ganz.
Ja, das ist, das ist eigentlich nicht so, nicht so ganz richtig.
Aber, ja, so, so ungefähr.
Das ist übrigens blöd, wenn ich das Play mal, hier, du wirst es JSON nennen, so, so.
Also, mal angenommen, ich habe einen JSON-String.
Und den will ich quasi deserialisieren in ein Objekt, oder in ein struct, oder in eine Klasse, oder so.
Das ist was, was eigentlich so gut wie mit jeder JSON-Response passiert.
Du musst ja mit dem, mit dem JSON-String allein kannst du ja nichts anfangen.
Du willst ja mit dem JSON-String irgendwas machen.
Ja?
Und am besten ist, das Ding in irgendein Format zu deserialisieren, mit dem man dann ordentlich weiterarbeiten kann.
Und das ist halt in struct eine Klasse, oder irgendein dynamisches Objekt, wo ich dann, ja, was, was auch, was auch möglich wäre,
dass ich jetzt sagen würde, JSON irgendwie dynamic, oder sowas, ja, irgendwie.
Und dann sagen könnte, hier, blub, A, und so, ja.
Aber ich will ja, also der JSON-String alleine, worauf ich raus will, der JSON-String alleine, mit dem kannst du ja nichts anfangen.
Du willst ja irgendwas mit den Daten in diesem JSON machen.
So.
Und, so gut wie jede Sprache hat sowas eingebaut.
Go hat sowas eingebaut, Java, wobei, Java bin ich, ich glaube auch, ja.
C-Sharp, Python, du hast überall einen JSON-Parser.
JSON-Parser, Serializer, Deserializer drin, das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Nicht so in C++.
In C++ gibt es sowas nicht.
So.
Es gibt ein paar Libraries, die sind auch ganz gut.
Mit denen kann man sowas machen.
Mit denen kann man zum Beispiel einen JSON-String nehmen und ihn deserializen in ein struct.
Also eines, eines der most basic Sachen, was man mit solchen, mit JSON-Daten machen möchte.
Das Problem ist jetzt nur, dass diese Libraries ultra, extremely kompliziert sind.
Weil C++ so eine Schrott-Sprache ist.
Denn, in C++ ist es nicht so ohne weiteres möglich, sowas hier zu machen.
Sowas zu deserializen.
Dass du einfach mal sagst, hier, das dahin.
Ich kann euch jetzt nicht genau die, die, die innere, ja, wie diese Libraries funktionieren erklären, zumindest.
Ich hab mich letztens mal auf die Suche gemacht, nach einer JSON-Library.
Die JSON-Strings in structs deserialisieren kann in C++.
Und das findet man.
Aber diese Libraries sind alle super kompliziert und advanced und dadurch fehleranfällig.
So dass beispielsweise auf dem ESP32 davon gar nicht, also viele davon gar nicht funktionieren.
Es gibt zum Beispiel, ja, JSON, diesen, irgendwas mit Neumann oder wie, Lohmann heißt der Typ.
Ja.
Zum Beispiel so eine JSON, die ist super langsam.
So.
Und der Typ hat, der muss, der muss sich wirklich das Bein ausreißen, dass der sowas hier auf die Reihe bekommt.
Quasi JSON-String deserialisieren in irgendwelche Objekte.
Und selbst dann funktioniert das nicht richtig.
Ja, die Beispiele sind halt wieder komplett pepega, ne.
Aber, das da.
To from Strings.
In was deserialisiert er das jetzt?
Ich check das Beispiel nicht.
Ja.
Und du musst jetzt, im Endeffekt musst du jede deiner Klasse irgendwie annotaten, mit irgendwelchen komischen Makros, dass sowas hier möglich ist.
Und selbst dann funktioniert es nicht richtig.
Es ist einfach für den Arsch, ja.
Dass solche Basic-Sachen nicht funktionieren.
Und das, es gibt, es gibt dazu Vorschläge für den Standard, wie man sowas machen könnte.
Aber die werden halt einfach seit Jahren nicht umgesetzt.
Seit Jahren nicht umgesetzt.
So gut wie jede Sprache kann das, C++ kann das nicht gescheit.
Und ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie ich da drauf gekommen bin.
Mario, danke schön für den Sub.
Und, was hab ich noch übersehen?
Wartet mal.
Splexa, danke für den Sub.
Gar nicht gesehen.
OMG.
Ja.
Hm.
Dazu kommt noch, und das muss ich jetzt auch nochmal loswerden.
Dazu kommt noch, dass C++ nicht mal, und da würde man ja eigentlich überlegen, das ist das einfachste auf der Welt.
Aber ist es nicht.
Jason ist super gemacht in Go.
Ja.
Aber da denken die C++-Leute nicht dran, vielleicht mal was Sinnvolles einzubauen.
Also das, was ich meine, C++ ist nicht bloated in dem Sinne von, da ist der dritte Timer oder so in der Standard-Library.
Ne, C++ ist bloated in Form von, dass du alles irgendwie auf fünf verschiedene Varianten erledigen kannst.
Und niemand so genau versteht instinktiv in C++, wann, wie, was passiert.
Ja.
Das fängt schon an mit, dass du Variablen übergeben kannst, ohne was, mit und, mit und und, ich weiß nicht, ob es dreifach und mittlerweile gibt, mit konst und und auto und haste nicht gesehen.
Wurde alles nicht so festgestellt, was passiert.
Dann hast du das Ding, dass manchmal Sachen kopiert werden, ohne dass du siehst, dass sie kopiert werden.
Dass manchmal Sachen gemovt werden, was quasi einen internen Pointer umschieben ist, ohne dass du selbst einen Pointer verwendest.
Also, das ist unglaublich schwierig zu erkennen, wann C++, ja genau, so was hier in der Richtung, wann C++ irgendwas macht.
Das stimmt, in Rust kannst du so Dinge auch alle machen.
Es geht nicht darum, dass man die machen kann, sondern dass eindeutig ist, was passiert.
Komplizierter Rust-Code ist auch alles andere als gut lesbar.
Das hören, das ist übrigens eines meiner Punkte, warum ich immer sage, dass es für Alltagssoftware nicht wirklich geeignet ist.
So, und jetzt kommt das Schlimmste, dass C++ noch nicht mal gut zusammen mit C funktioniert.
Man könnte ja eigentlich sagen, C++ ist die perfekte Ergänzung für reines C.
Man nimmt einfach nur die Sachen, die nicht so einfach funktionieren.
Und erweitert damit ein bisschen so seine C-Programme, um Sachen, die einem sonst halt zu kompliziert wären, selbst zu machen.
Aber noch nicht mal...
Doch, doch, C++ funktioniert... Naja, nein, C++ funktioniert nicht zwangsläufig mit C.
Und zwar, ich zeige euch jetzt mal ein Beispiel, wo C++ nicht mit C funktioniert.
Das machen wir jetzt auch wieder so Pseudo-Pseudo-mäßig.
Wobei, wir müssen das gar nicht Pseudo-mäßig machen.
Ich zeige euch ein reales Beispiel.
Mute mal das jetzt.
Ja, reales C++-Beispiel, Leute, ja?
Alles klar, oder?
Ne, das ist vielleicht kein gutes Beispiel gewesen.
So, ich zeige euch mal ein reales, echtes Beispiel, wo C++ nicht mit C funktioniert.
Und zwar...
Ihr müsst euch den Code überhaupt nicht angucken.
Es geht mir nur um das hier.
Exakt um die Geschichte.
Das können wir sogar hier rauskopieren, ja?
Wir machen mal alles andere weg.
Kopieren das hier mal hin.
Also...
Das ist letztendlich Instruct.
Wo ein paar Sachen zugewiesen werden.
Worum es mir geht, ist um diese Händler-Geschichte.
Händler ist ein Function-Pointer.
Also, im Prinzip ist das hier für...
Das hier ist quasi der Endpoint für einen Web-Server.
Du sagst dem, hier zum Beispiel, hier, post.
So registrierst du in dieser Library einen Endpoint für einen Web-Server.
Ich glaube, das wird jeder...
Das kann man übrigens alles weglassen.
Das versteht man, wenn man sich das so anguckt, ja?
Wenn man sagt, ey, Web-Server, ich möchte, dass du unter Slash-Update,
wenn ein HTTP-Get kommt...
Also, wenn ein HTTP-Get unter dieser URL kommt,
unter diesem Part kommt,
dann ruft diese Methode auf,
um eben das zu handeln.
Diesen Request, ja?
Also, das hier wird aufgerufen.
Der kümmert sich dann um diesen HTTP-Request, diese Funktion.
Das ist jetzt eigentlich nichts so kompliziertes.
Ich glaube, wenn man sich das anguckt, versteht man das, was passiert.
Das hier ist ein C-Style-Function-Pointer.
Und zwar möchte das Ding eine Methode haben,
beziehungsweise eine Funktion haben,
die folgende Signatur hat.
Return-Wert ESP-Error als Option ein HTTP-Request.
So, wenn wir uns die Methode angucken, dann sieht das so aus.
So sieht die Methode...
...Signatur aus.
Also, soweit eigentlich klar.
Der Rest könnt ihr...
Das ist egal, was hier drunter passiert, ja?
Also, im Prinzip das, was man im Prinzip in C-Sharp,
wenn man jetzt Minimal-APIs verwendet,
auch so macht, ja?
Wenn man jetzt beispielsweise einen Mini-Web-Server baut für .NET,
dann macht man das hier ja auch so.
Guckt mal hier.
ab.map.get.slash
Und das ist quasi die Funktion, die hier aufgerufen wird.
Also, im Prinzip ist das hier mehr oder weniger das Gleiche wie das.
So.
Und jetzt kommt der Fall, wie wo C++ nicht mehr funktioniert mit C.
Das hier möchte einen Function-Pointer haben.
Jetzt könnte man sich ja denken,
okay, wie wäre es denn, wenn wir das Ganze jetzt ein bisschen schöner machen,
und zwar mit ein paar Features, die uns C++ bietet, über C.
Und zwar, wir könnten beispielsweise es machen, wie in .NET,
dass wir sagen, ey, solange das Ganze eigentlich nichts anderes machen soll,
wie Hello World zurückgeben bei einem Aufruf,
dann machen wir das hier einfach als...
Machen wir den Callback so als Lambda-anonyme Funktion inline.
Könnte man sagen, easy, machen wir.
Sieht in C++ eh schon ein bisschen hässlich aus.
Können wir sagen, wir machen jetzt hier sowas.
Natürlich muss man, weil das C++ ist, die Parameter hier angeben.
Ups, jetzt hat das formatiert. Das soll aber auch nicht formatieren.
Ich will nur, dass ihr euch anguckt.
So, dann brauchen wir noch einen Return-Wert.
So. Das funktioniert auch.
Also, jetzt haben wir in dem Fall tatsächlich C und C++ schön verbunden.
Das macht jetzt hier, im Prinzip ruft das nur das auf.
Ich brauche jetzt keine eigene Funktion mehr bauen.
Das ist quasi das Gleiche, so wie das in C Sharp hier aussieht.
Nur hier in diesem C++-Framework.
Das ist soweit okay.
So. Und jetzt kommt der Punkt, wo eigentlich C++ sich richtig anbieten würde,
es sich aber nicht macht.
Und zwar, es könnte jetzt ja sein, dass ich sowas hier habe.
int i gleich 1.
So. Und vielleicht möchte ich ja in diesem Händler auf i zugreifen.
Warum auch immer. Vielleicht will ich aus irgendwelchen Gründen i loggen.
So. Und jetzt geht das nicht.
Warum geht das nicht?
Weil i hier außen ist und ich von hier innen nicht auf i zugreifen kann.
Das ist eh schon ein bisschen weird, wie sie das gemacht haben in C++.
In .NET würde das beispielsweise einfach funktionieren.
Das liegt daran, weil diese Funktion i nicht capturet.
In .NET passiert das automatisch.
Es kommt dann quasi alles in die sogenannte Closure mit rein.
Das ist quasi der Kontext von dieser Funktion.
In C++ muss man sagen, ey, wenn du von so einem Callback hier, von so einer anonymen Funktion,
auf was zugreifen willst, was außerhalb ist,
dann musst du das explizit sagen, dass du das machen willst.
Sondern das sagt man in C++, indem man beispielsweise hier ein und macht
oder ein gleich reinmacht.
Warum es ein und und ein gleich ist, man weiß es nicht.
Da haben sich die C++-Leute so ausgedacht.
Hu-dro-dings-fi-hil. Ich kann es nicht richtig aussprechen.
Aber dankeschön für den Prime-Sub. Excellent. Pog.
So. Der Unterschied, by the way, zwischen und und gleich ist komplett obvious, Leute, oder?
Also, man sieht sofort, was der Unterschied ist, oder?
Zwischen und und gleich.
Ist auch wieder so ein Ding, wo man sich denkt, wer hat sich das ausgedacht?
Also, der Unterschied zwischen und und gleich ist, dass bei einem und die Referenz auf i genommen wird.
Was geht heute?
Mich über C++ kurz auskotzen, dann geht's weiter.
Die Referenz auf i genommen wird, um hier auf i zuzugreifen.
Das heißt, wenn das hier out of scope gegangen wäre,
ist, bevor ich das hier aufrufe, crash das.
Auch geil, dass das überhaupt funktioniert.
Oder ich kann sagen, ich möchte nicht die Referenz nehmen, sondern ich will den Wert kopieren.
Das ist mit einem gleich.
Das heißt, zum Zeitpunkt, wo ich das hier überhaupt erst anlege, wird einmalig der Wert von i kopiert
und steht mir dann hier drin zur Verfügung.
Und wenn ich danach i anpasse, also in dem Fall, wenn ich das jetzt so machen würde,
dann wäre hier drin immer noch i 1.
Und mit einem und.
Wenn das später ausgeführt wird, wäre i dann hier drinne 2.
Egal, hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Wollte ich nur mal so nebenbei erwähnen.
Und jetzt kommt das Dumme an C.
Sobald ich das hier an C++...
Ja, haben wir schon, haben wir schon.
Sobald ich das hier mache, funktioniert der Callback nicht mehr.
Weil...
Obvious Fehlermeldung.
Versteht auch keiner, aber ich kann euch erklären, was das bedeutet.
Du kannst ein C++...
Eine anonyme Funktion ist ein C++-Feature.
Nichts als raw C-Function-Pointer verwenden.
Das geht nicht.
Warum?
Weil die Leute keinen Bock hatten, ein bisschen Compiler-Magic einzubauen.
Das wäre eines der Anwendungsszenarien für C++ gewesen.
Interop.
Etwas schönerer C-Code.
Aber das geht an vielen Stellen nicht.
Weil die keinen Bock hatten.
Du kannst sowas hier nicht verwenden,
um es mit oldschool C-Funktionen zu verwenden.
Das geht nicht.
Und es hat sicherlich seine Gründe, warum es nicht geht.
Aber es sind keine Gründe, warum man das nicht mit irgendwelcher Compile-Magic hätte fixen können.
Ich kann es ja selbst fixen.
Ich kann das in einer statischen Variable zuordnen und das dann da rein schieben.
Funktioniert tut das alles.
Aber warum geht sowas nicht?
Wenn C++ nicht gemacht dafür ist,
gutes Interop mit C zu haben,
dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Und das ist halt ultra abfuck.
Und wo ich mir denke, wie kann man in der Kerndisziplin
schon so scheitern,
möglichst guten Interop mit C zu haben?
C++ wäre wie gemacht dafür,
normales C zu erweitern mit den Sachen, wo es Sinn macht.
Und an der Stelle bin ich der Meinung,
würde es absolut Sinn machen,
anstatt einen plain oldschool Function-Pointer zu verwenden,
wie man das in C gemacht hätte,
beispielsweise hier so eine anonyme Funktion inline hinzuschreiben.
Aber es macht halt keinen Sinn,
dass das nur geht, wenn man nichts capturen kann.
Weil dann kann ich auch wieder eine plain Function-Pointer verwenden.
Das sind so Dinger, wo ich mir denke,
fuck, Alter, warum ist das so schlecht?
Nee, C++ war immer scheiße.
Modernes C++ hat den gleichen Scheiß drinne,
den alten C++ hatte nur noch mehr Scheiß.
Die Standard-Library von C++ ist nicht bloated,
die ist eher sehr lacking im Vergleich zu vielen anderen Standard-Libraries.
Und dazu kommt, dass du in C++ nichts machen kannst,
wo du direkt erkennst, wie es sich verhalten würde.
Es wird kopiert an Stellen, wo du nicht damit denkst, dass es kopiert wird,
weil implizit irgendwas überschrieben ist,
copy, constructor, es werden Sachen kopiert,
da willst du nicht, dass es kopiert wird.
Es wird manche Sachen gemovet, da willst du nicht, dass es gemovet wird.
Du kannst, es ist nicht möglich, es ist nicht möglich, ohne Scheiß, Leute,
es ist nicht möglich, C++ ohne Fehler.
Zu programmieren, selbst ganz simple Sachen, das geht einfach nicht.
Weil es immer irgendwelche unvorhergesehenen Dinger gibt,
die versteckt sind, die du nicht erkennst beim ersten Mal angucken.
In Rust haben sie es ganz gut gelöst,
in Rust kompiliert das meiste Zeug schon gar nicht, was du nicht haben willst.
Aber auch in anderen Programmiersprachen ist es in der Regel relativ offensichtlich,
was bei simplen Konstrukten funktioniert, ja.
In C Sharp beispielsweise kannst du sagen, ey, es wird im Prinzip alles immer als Referenz übergeben.
Und wenn nicht, dann siehst du es.
Aber es ist, es ist wie, also wie gesagt, C++ ist eigentlich schon immer Scheiße gewesen
und ist heute eigentlich beschissener denn je, weil noch viel komplexer als früher.
Max, hast du mitbekommen, dass die Telekom den Rückzug eines Root-Zertifikats,
ne, ne, gibt es da irgendeine Newspost dazu?
Das habe ich nicht mitbekommen.
So, aber jetzt habe ich mich erst genug über...
Wie bin ich da überhaupt drauf gekommen?
Ach so, ja, ob, ähm, ob Go in Zukunft wie C++ werden wird, ne.
Also meiner Meinung nach wird Go nicht werden wie C++.
C++, so wie C++ wird keine andere Sprache werden,
weil ich glaube, das ist, das, das schafft keiner mehr.
Also um, um so zu werden wie C++,
musst du schon aktiv wissentlich Scheiße einbauen.
Inkonsis-, wissentlich inkonsistente Scheiße einbauen, dass du C++ werden kannst.
Telekom Security, ach, das ist vor sechs Monaten.
Das ist mir jetzt zu high IQ, das checke ich nicht.
Die wollten nicht zurückziehen, weil ihre Kunden wichtiger waren.
Ja gut, Stonks regelt halt Geld.
Ist natürlich blöd, wenn SSL-Zertifikate revoked werden, aber die werden nicht revoked.
Das ist halt, äh, eines, das untergräbt halt eines der grundsätzlichen Security-Mechanismen von, ähm, SSL.
Ohne mir das jetzt genauer angeguckt zu haben.
Ja, Go ist an sich keine schlechte Sprache.
Also, wenn ich, wenn ich die Auswahl hätte zwischen Go und C++, ist es bei mir überhaupt keine Frage.
Es wäre immer Go.
Leider ist halt Go in manchen Bereichen, gerade wenn du irgendwelche Microcontroller programmierst oder so,
im gleichen Level von den Möglichkeiten wie C++.
Leider.
Ansonsten würde ich Go auch immer vorziehen.
Ich muss aber auch ehrlich sagen, dort, wo ich die Auswahl habe, würde ich tatsächlich C Sharp und .NET auch immer Go vorziehen.
Aber es macht schon durchaus Sinn, in manchen Bereichen Go zu verwenden.
Zum Beispiel, wo es meiner Meinung nach extrem, also sehr viel Sinn macht, Go zu verwenden,
ist, wenn du irgendwelche Standalone-Kommandozeilen-Tools bauen willst, die Standalone funktionieren.
Wo du einfach einen Binary rüberkopierst.
Also generell alles, was möglichst wenig externe Dependencies haben soll und einfach nur funktionieren soll,
ist Go das Beste, was es gibt.
Es gibt MicroGo, es gibt TinyGo, aber das ist bei weitem noch nicht so weit, dass du da mit gescheiten ESP32 programmieren könntest.
Ja, also für alles, wo es möglichst Standalone-Binaries geht, ist Go das Beste, was es gibt.
Not even close. Es gibt nichts, was irgendwie in die Nähe kommt.
Nudel mit Lachs tut sich heute.
Eine Sache, die vielleicht auch noch von der Verwendung her, sagen wir mal, da rankommt,
wäre, aber damit kannst du natürlich nicht so viel machen,
wäre beispielsweise statisch gelinktes Rust gegen Musel.
Ja, das ist auch Standalone lauffähig gegen so gut wie alles.
Aber sobald du irgendwelche Sachen, Abhängigkeiten hast,
du kannst vergessen, Go ist immer dann gut, wenn es möglichst Standalone sein soll.
Sobald du von Go auf irgendwas nicht Go-mäßiges zugreifen willst, wird es eklig.
Dann verschenkst du viele Vorteile von Go.
Weiterer Vorteil von Go ist, um jetzt mal nicht so sehr mit der Sprache selbst zu reden,
dass Go ein ziemlich gutes Ökosystem hat.
Also es gibt sehr viele richtig gute Libraries, wo ich sagen würde,
dass es sogar die besten Libraries für diese eine Sache in Go gibt.
Zum Beispiel WebRTC.
Meiner Meinung nach hat Go die mit Abstand beste WebRTC-Library,
die es gibt, das hier.
Hat auch nur 13.000 Scherzen.
Aus meiner Sicht gibt es keine andere WebRTC-Library,
die ähnlich komplett und gut und einfach nur funktioniert.
Also Go hat schon ein paar coole Sachen.
Und Go an sich, die Sprache ist auch auszuhalten.
Das ist nicht so wie in C++, wo du nach ein paar Tagen komplett dem Wahnsinn verfällst oder so.
Aber Go hält man schon aus.
Es sind ja auch genug Sachen richtig eklig in Go, aber es ist okay.
Aber für Standalone-Binary-Sachen ist Go einfach das Beste, was es gibt.
Für Standalone-CLI-Tools beispielsweise ist Go das Beste, was es gibt.
Hat schon seinen Grund, warum im Cloud-Umfeld so vieles in Go programmiert ist.
Ah, ja, Proc-Subscription.
Was denkst du darüber, dass Go mit Pointern arbeitet?
Alle anderen programmierenden Apps finde ich nicht schlimm an der Stelle.
Ich fände es in Go manchmal auch ein bisschen undurchsichtig.
Manchmal, was so der Unterschied ist.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du eine Map hast.
Sag mal, du hast eine Map mit Strings oder du hast eine Map mit Pointer zu Strings.
Manchmal habe ich den Eindruck, unter der Haube würde Go das schon richtig machen, ohne dass du selbst Pointer verwendest und manchmal nicht.
So ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten habe ich da auch manchmal in Go zu checken, wann man es jetzt selbst mit einem Pointer machen muss.
Und wann es manchmal irgendwie das mit einem Slice oder so unter der Haube schon für einen macht.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen finde ich das okay.
Sofern man davon ausgehen kann, und das kann man in Go ja eigentlich auch.
Wenn du eine Referenz willst, schreibst du einen Pointer hin.
Sobald du kopieren willst, schreibst du keinen Pointer hin.
Und das ist ja in Go in 95% der Fälle so.
Sofern das immer eindeutig ist, ist klar.
Sofern das nicht eindeutig ist, wie das in C++ teilweise so ist, dann ist es eklig.
Ich finde das kein Problem, dass es eine Pointer so einen Tag skippt.
Das habe ich glaube ich schon mal gesehen.
Endlich hat das mal einer was gescheites gebaut in der Richtung.
Ich bilde mir ein, ich habe mir das aber auch letztens angeguckt und das hatte auch irgendwas, was ich doof fand.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall schon mal viel angenehmer, wie einfach Vorschleife.
Das ist Link für Arme quasi, ja.
Es ist auch so ein Ding, was ich halt auch ein bisschen doof finde, aber das gette ich in Go, warum das nicht geht.
Dass du nicht schreiben kannst array.filter, sondern dass du schreiben musst lofilter und als erstes Argument das Array übergeben musst.
Du kannst in Go, du darfst ja für Go quasi Typen, die nicht dir sind, irgendwie nicht erweitern, ne.
Deswegen geht das nicht.
Aber jetzt irgendwie, ich habe mich wieder eine Stunde über C++ aufgekriegt, kann das sein?
Assembler plus CPython, jetzt wird...
Ja, wieso?
Ich finde, das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Wenn du wirklich genau wissen musst, was passiert, dann das da, ansonsten das, warum nicht?
Ja, gut, jeder, was er will.
Gar nicht.
Ich werde ja mit simplen Sachen schon nicht fertig.
Übrigens, was meint ihr?
Brockchamp, erwähnt schon Brockchamp.
Ich habe jetzt gelesen, RMV, das ist hier bei mir in Frankfurt in der Ecke, da kann man seine Fahrkarten und so drüber kaufen.
Und zwar, ich habe jetzt gelesen...
Ich habe gelesen auf Reddit, dass der RMV...
Vielleicht sollte ich mal Google suchen, dann findet er das vielleicht.
Ich habe gelesen, dass...
Genau, dass man jetzt nur noch...
Dass man jetzt, wenn man per Lastschrift bezahlen will, dass es jetzt nicht mehr über die App geht, sondern...
Dass man jetzt irgendwie über Tick...
Ich finde das nicht, keine Ahnung.
Da gab es, da gab es irgendwie...
Weiß ich nicht, warum ich das...
Das war doch innerhalb der letzten Woche.
Google, Google-Ergebnisse sind ja richtig bepeger.
Zumindest kann man jetzt nicht mehr über...
Keine Ahnung, Google.
Man kann jetzt nicht mehr über Lastschrift direkt bezahlen, sondern muss das irgendwie über einen Drittanbieter lösen.
Und das Ding ist, ich habe ein Deutschland-Ticket-Abo.
Anscheinend, ja, wahrscheinlich, weil es auch irgendwie...
Ich habe ja ein Deutschland-Ticket-Abo und das wird über Lastschrift bezahlt.
Was meint ihr, was passieren wird am 1. August?
Meint ihr, ich sitze dann in der Bahn und das Ding hat einfach mein Abo nicht verlängert?
Oder ich bekomme noch eine Meldung dazu, dass es nicht möglich ist, zu verlängern im Vorfeld?
Meint ihr, sie sind scheiße oder sie sind so richtig Hurensohn-Scheiße?
Um es jetzt mal so extrem zu sagen.
Meint ihr, sie sind unfähig oder richtig krass unfähig?
Was ist am 1. August?
Das Ticket wird automatisch ausgestellt normalerweise.
Also, ich rechne damit...
Also, okay, vielleicht hat man das nicht so ganz verstanden, was ich meine.
Also, ich habe ein Abo in der RMV-App für ein Deutschland-Ticket.
Das verlängert sich immer am 1. des jeweiligen Monats.
Das Ganze wird bezahlt über Lastschrift.
Das heißt, ich rechne eigentlich damit,
dass ich, ohne dass ich was machen muss, einfach jeden Monat ein neues Ticket bekomme.
Und wenn ich dann mal im Bezug kontrolliert wäre, hole ich meine App raus und zeige dir mein Ticket.
So, und jetzt habe ich aber gelesen auf Reddit,
dass es anscheinend Probleme gibt mit Lastschrift-Abbuchungen
und man das jetzt irgendwie nur noch über einen externen Lastschrift-Anbieter machen kann
und nicht mal direkt in der App.
Ich habe gestern in die App geguckt.
In der App steht immer noch, ich habe ein gültiges Ticket.
Es wird automatisch am 1. August verlängert.
So, und was meint ihr jetzt, was passiert?
Prediction.
Wenn die mir eine Meldung schicken, Achtung, Herr Max,
Ihr Ticket kann nicht automatisch verlängert werden.
Ich habe einen Screenshot gemacht.
Und sie fahren nur noch bis Ende Juni.
Ich bekomme eine Message.
Achtung, Herr Max, Ihr Ticket wird nicht mehr automatisch verlängert
und Sie haben ab August kein Ticket mehr.
Oder wird einfach gar nichts kommen.
Und ich würde, wenn ich nicht selbst daran denke, im August ohne Ticket dastehen.
Was meint ihr, was passieren wird?
Ich habe mir einen Reminder gesetzt für 1. August 7.20 Uhr zum Nachgucken.
Ploppt dann auf dem Handy auf.
Aber das sind Sachen, also wenn das wirklich so ist,
wenn das wirklich so ist, dass das einfach sich nicht verlängert,
dann ist das vermutlich keine Info.
Vielleicht, es könnte auch sein, dass es einfach funktioniert,
weil ja mein Account schon eine Weile geht und man weiß,
dass da nicht beschissen wird über das Konto, kann schon sein.
Aber wenn das einfach von heute auf morgen,
obwohl immer noch vollkommen keine Fehler, nichts angezeigt wird,
gültiges Abo, alles, wenn das einfach nicht funktioniert am 1. August,
dann ist das ein richtiger Hurensohn-Move.
Anders kann ich das nicht sagen.
Ihr wisst, ich verwende normalerweise solche Kraft,
ich fluche mal ganz gerne, aber das selten.
Aber das wäre so absoluter Ultrascheiß-Move,
dass so einfach die Leute, die nicht mal wirklich wollen,
es ist ja nicht so, als wollen die Leute dann schwarz fahren,
dann fahren einfach tausende Leute schwarz,
weil jeder denkt, er hat ein Ticket
und er hat auf einmal kein Ticket mehr,
weil es keine Benachrichtigung gab,
dass es Probleme mit der Verlängerung gab.
Also mir hat der RMV noch gar nichts geschickt.
Würde der RMV was schicken, wäre das ja okay.
Nichts in der App steht drinnen.
Ich mach die mal kurz auf.
RMV.
Über PayPal geht nicht.
Das Deutschlandticket kann man nicht über PayPal kaufen,
nur weil das gerade jemand gefragt hat.
Deutschlandticket kann man nur über Lastschrift machen.
Über Lastschrift machen, hier.
Meine Tickets, Active Tickets, Deutschlandticket, Juli.
Your Deutschland, pass auf, das steht da drinnen,
ich hab sogar gescreenshottet.
Your Deutschlandticket will automatically renew
on 1. August 2024.
Das steht da wortwörtlich drinnen.
Und jetzt wisst ihr, warum mich das so aufregt,
wenn das nicht der Fall sein sollte.
Stellt euch vor, das geht einfach nicht
und das Ding gibt keine Nachricht.
Da sitzen am 1. August tausende Leute im Zug
und haben kein gültiges Ticket und wissen es nicht.
Und rechnen auch nicht damit, dass sie kein gültiges Ticket haben.
Und erst wenn sie nachgucken müssen,
weil sie mal kontrolliert werden, stellen sie fest,
ups, ich hab ja kein gültiges Ticket.
Übrigens wisst ihr, was ich auch schon mal hatte,
was auch geil ist, richtig geil.
Die RMV App, die timeoutet öfters mal das Login.
Ist ja auch okay.
Da loggt man sich ein in der App
und dann bekommt man wahrscheinlich unter der Haube
irgendeinen Session-Token, das gilt halt 30 Tage.
Und danach muss man sich neu einloggen.
Das Problem ist, das hatte ich schon mal,
das Problem ist, die App sagt dir nicht,
bitte neu einloggen.
Selbst wenn du sie startest, wenn du die App aufmachst,
sieht alles okay aus.
Nur, dass unter My Active Tickets
das Ticket vom letzten Monat drin steht,
nicht das von diesem Monat.
Und dann willst du refreshen und du refreshst die Seite
und du stellst fest, Pull to Refresh ist bei dir noch nicht angekommen.
Pull to Refresh gibt es nicht auf der Seite.
Und du denkst dir, Alter, wo ist denn mein aktuelles Ticket?
Und dann musst du auf More gehen, auf dein Account
und dann sagt er dir, ah, okay, sie wurden abgemeldet.
Und dann musst du dich einloggen
und dann siehst du es wieder unter deinen Tickets.
Das sagt dir nichts.
Das ist wirklich wieder die Unfähigkeit pur,
wenn ich mir diese App angucke.
Und das hatte ich schon.
Okay, also ich höre es besser gesagt.
Ich höre, ah, okay, Schaffner, Kontrollstelz am Start.
Holst das Handy raus, ich hol das Handy raus, guck rein.
Äh, mein Ticket ist vom letzten Monat.
Warum ist es nicht von diesem Monat?
App ausgemacht, App angemacht.
Es lädt einfach keine neuen Tickets.
Hm, geht nicht, geht nicht.
Klick ich ein bisschen drin, nee, wir haben noch gar nichts geguckt.
Klick ich ein bisschen drin rum, stell fest, ach Mist.
Ach Mist.
Ähm, es hat mich ausgeloggt.
Loggst du dich ein?
Und was war? Wir waren in Maintal.
Wart ihr schon mal in Maintal?
Ihr müsst nicht in Maintal gewesen sein, das ist vollkommen rein rhetorische Frage.
In Maintal habt ihr kein Handyempfang am Bahnhof.
Warum auch immer.
Warum auch immer man es schafft, im Jahr 2024 in Maintal am Bahnhof kein Handyempfang zu haben.
Ich war in Maintal im Zug, da fahre ich vorbei manchmal so.
Und auf der Zugstrecke zwischen Maintal Süd und Maintal Ost oder was das ist,
dort hast du kein Handyempfang. Der ist weg.
Wir waren schon. Gibt es dort kein Handyempfang.
Und es ist nicht nur so, dass, dass, äh, äh, was hat O2 für Netz?
Ist das noch das alte E-Plus Netz?
D2? Nee, keine Ahnung.
Es ist nicht nur, es ist nicht nur, dass E-Plus keinen Empfang hat,
Telekom und so hat auch keinen Empfang dort.
Da ist einfach nichts. Ich weiß nicht warum.
So, und da willst du dich dann da einloggen und kannst dich nicht einloggen,
weil du in Maintal bist auf der Strecke und Handy haben keine Verbindung.
Es ist halt einfach mal für den Arsch, ne?
Du kommst dir manchmal vor wie im Mittelalter hier.
Also da bin ich, bin ich, wie gesagt, ich habe mir extra einen Reminder gesetzt auf 1. August.
Wegen dem, wegen dem Ticket.
Und sollte das wirklich der Fall sein, dass das nicht erneuert wird.
Ich werde die so hart des Todes flamen auf Twitter.
Warte, eher auf Twitter. Sind die überhaupt, sind die überhaupt auf Twitter?
Sind sie.
Ich werde die so flamen, dass die mich bannen.
Dann bin ich nicht nur von MSI, von MSI bin ich gar nicht mehr gebannt.
Die haben mich wieder entbannt.
Ich werde die so lange flamen, bis die mich bannen.
Wenn das wirklich der Fall sein sollte.
Das kommt drauf an.
Bei der Bahn ist es wohl auch ein Problem mit Lastschrift.
Aber ich benutze, ich benutze die RMV App.
Es ist eigentlich im Nachhinein ziemlich dumm gewesen,
dass ich die RMV App benutzt habe, um mein Deutschlandticket zu kaufen.
Weil, also ich habe die RMV App verwendet,
weil ich die halt für die sonst, für die, für die vorhergehenden Fahrkarten immer verwendet habe.
Und da hatte ich halt meine Fahrkarte drin,
habe mir für nächsten Monat darin halt auch das Deutschlandticket gekauft.
Das war blöd. Wahrscheinlich hätte ich die offizielle Bahn App verwenden sollen dafür.
Ja, ja, genau.
Da musst du, das musst du mit Tink machen.
Genau. Ich habe, ich habe, also bei mir, also ich muss das nicht machen.
Ich war da übrigens gestern drinne.
Bei mir steht da nichts großartig drinne.
Und meine, mein Konto ist ja schon hinterlegt.
Also es besteht die Möglichkeit, dass es einfach weiter funktioniert.
Die Möglichkeit besteht ja.
Also es kann immer noch sein, dass es einfach weitergeht, ja.
Und Kreditkartenbezahlung will ich nicht machen.
Weil Kreditkartenbezahlung für ein Abo echt doof ist,
weil die Kreditkarte läuft auch irgendwann ab.
Und du denkst nicht dran, dass da dann, dass da ein Abo dagegen läuft.
Lastschrift ist mit Abstand das Beste für so ein komisches Abo.
Und ich habe ja noch gar nicht mal ein Problem damit, wenn du was machen musst.
Ja, auch wenn ich keinen Bock habe, da Tink zu verwenden.
Ähm, gar kein Problem.
Was ich, was ich, was ich habe, was für mich ja der richtige Arschmove ist,
dass das Ding keine, wenn es, wenn das denn so ist, keine Meldung anzeigt,
dass die Verlängerung fehlgeschlagen ist.
Das wäre für mich der eigentliche Fail, wofür ich die auch flamen werde,
bis sie mich bannen auf Twitter.
Ich muss mal kurz Licht anmachen.
Hier ist es gerade übelst dunkel.
Sieht so aus, als gibt es gleich, es sieht so unwettermäßig aus.
Okay, jetzt war ich richtig dumm, Leute.
Jetzt war ich richtig dumm.
Ich bin gerade aufgestanden und mit so einem Schalter gelaufen, um das Licht anzuschalten.
Ich hätte auch einfach auf dem zweiten Monitor einfach meinen Home Assistant aufmachen können,
auf den Knopf drücken.
Warum bin ich dafür aufgestanden, Alter?
Wirst du sie loben, wenn alles perfekt funktioniert?
Nee.
Ich glaube, dass solche Basic-Sachen wie ein automatisches Abo auch automatisch funktioniert.
Ich lobe doch auch nicht jeden dafür, dass er vorwärts laufen kann, ohne umzufallen.
Ja, richtig.
Steinzeit.
Wobei in der Steinzeit, ich muss ja sagen, als Höhlenmensch, die wären froh gewesen,
wenn sie einfach nur aufstehen müssten, auf den Schalter drücken und das Licht geht an.
Die hatten da noch andere Probleme.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich alle Updates gemacht?
Ja, ne?
Ich habe schon wieder neue Arch, by the way.
Naja, okay.
Alles klar.
So, lang genug rumgemeckert.
Alles Mögliche jetzt.
Ausgekotzt.
Wunderbar.
Muss auch ab und zu mal sein, ne?
By the way, wollen wir was zum Kacken sehen?
Okay, ich quäle euch nicht länger damit.
Habe ich letztens auf Stack Overflow gefunden?
Ich habe letztens auf Stack Overflow gesucht,
wie ich das, was ich euch hier vorhin versucht habe zu zeigen,
ob man das nicht irgendwie lösen kann.
Und das war die Antwort, die ich auf Stack Overflow gefunden habe dazu.
Seriously.
Und es funktioniert noch nicht mal.
Es ist ja der Witz, es funktioniert noch nicht mal.
Es macht nicht das, was man denkt, was es macht.
Wer hätte das auch gedacht?
I mean, obviously, self-documenting, sehr readable code.
Ich meine, es ist klar, was es macht, oder?
Also, ich meine, wer das hier nicht versteht auf den ersten Blick,
Kacknoob, Mann.
Gibt es wirklich jemanden, der das nicht versteht?
Jetzt ernsthaft, wir formatieren es sogar mal.
Es sieht sogar formatiert noch hässlich aus.
Also, wer das nicht versteht, dem ist ja auch nicht mehr zu helfen.
Ich finde, das ist ein typisches Beispiel für
guter Code dokumentiert sich selbst.
Es sind einfach jegliche Dokumentationen, Kommentare und Tests
überflüssig dafür.
Man erkennt es einfach, sofort, auf den ersten Blick.
Das ist so eine Scheißsprache, Mann.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich schlechter finde.
Die RMV-Ticketverlängerung oder das?
Okay, genug.
Ja, also, ist doch klar, Mann.
Ja, vor allem, der Unterschied ist ja, es ist was anderes,
wenn es args 1 ist oder args 1.
Args 1, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, ist in Wirklichkeit
eigentlich gar nicht nur ein Argument,
sondern beliebig viele Argumente, obwohl es args 1 heißt.
Warum? Tja, man weiß es nicht.
Oh, Mann.
So, das Fireship-Video, nee, das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Du meinst das hier, gell? Zu CrowdStrike.
Ich habe ja mein Self zu CrowdStrike schon am Anfang des Tickets losgelassen.
Aber wir können uns noch mal angucken, was Fireship da ist.
Was Fireship dazu sagt.
Habe ich FireStrike gesagt gerade?
Fireship meine ich.
CrowdStrike, Fireship.
Was, Anfang des Tickets? Habe ich gesagt Anfang des Tickets?
Was?
Manchmal weiß ich selbst nicht, was ich gesagt habe.
So kleiner Biden-Moment.
Was habe ich gesagt?
Ich habe gesagt Anfang des Tickets.
Aber es ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn. Welches Ticket?
Welches Ticket?
Chat, ihr müsst mir jetzt erklären, was ich eigentlich gemeint habe.
Oder was wollte ich eigentlich sagen, als ich gesagt habe, Anfang des Tickets?
Stream-Ticket?
Anfang des Streams gleich Anfang des Tickets. Ach so.
Ja, wo ich gesagt habe, ich habe mich zu CrowdStrike schon am Anfang des Streams ausgelassen.
Ja.
Überlegt euch mal, überlegt euch mal.
Ich bin jetzt fast 40 und ich habe schon diese Probleme.
Biden ist doppelt so alt.
Was meint ihr, was der für Probleme erst hat?
Ich kann es mir ansatzweise vorstellen.
Mit 80 lese ich auch nur noch vom Teleprompter ab.
Wobei, da gibt es das wahrscheinlich schon als Augenimplantat oder sowas.
Oder ich bin zu agil.
Ich bin einfach zu sehr im agilen Mindset gefangen.
Biden hat noch nie C++ programmiert.
Da gehe ich von aus, dass er das noch nicht gemacht hat.
Aber das sollte eigentlich noch ein paar Gehirnzellen mehr übrig haben.
Ich meine, das kostet ja eher Gehirnzellen,
als dass es welche bringt.
Chat, ich hoffe, ihr seid auch sensibilisiert genug für agile Methoden.
Nicht, dass wir einen agilen, einen Agile-Wake-up-Call machen müssen mit euch.
Sonst macht es hier gleich Daily Scrum.
Kannst du dir vorstellen, wie es mir als Rentner geht,
da schon viele aus der IT raus sind.
Wie, das heißt, du bist noch älter als ich? Gibt es das nicht?
Ich dachte, ich bin der Älteste hier.
Okay, Chat, Chat.
Haben wir noch Leute, die älter als 40 sind?
Und wie viele Leute haben wir, die älter als ich sind?
Ich mache mal eine Umfrage.
Wer ist älter als Max?
Ich bin fast 40.
Wir machen mal kurz eine Umfrage.
Das interessiert mich jetzt.
Ich glaube, die meisten sind jünger, aber ein paar...
Ja, und außerdem...
Am besten sind es natürlich die Leute, die einfach
ich bin älter klicken, aber nicht älter sind, ja?
Es gibt wieder irgendwelche G-Baiter.
Moin, Michael, fünf Spieljahren.
Ohayo.
Ja, okay, aber das Verhältnis ist ungefähr klar.
Hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert, wenn es viele gibt.
Ohayo heißt Guten Morgen auf Japanisch.
Zumindest bilde ich mir das ein,
aus meinem in letzter Zeit gestiegenen Anime-Konsum rausgehört zu haben.
So interpretiere ich das zumindest,
dass das Guten Morgen auf Japanisch heißt.
So, dann gucken wir uns mal das Fireship wieder an.
Also, es geht noch mal um CrowdStrike.
Wie ich am Anfang des Tickets...
Ja, schon.
Am Anfang des Streams schon meinen Senf dazugegeben habe.
Mal gucken, was Fireship dazu sagt.
Nicht FireStrike, Fireship.
You should probably just go back to sleep,
because your Windows Work Computer
will likely have a blue screen of death.
Today, millions...
Übrigens, das ist ja auch so ein Ding.
Was es noch mal doppelt...
Das habe ich ja vorhin gar nicht erwähnt,
was es noch mal doppelt beschissen macht.
Du kannst diesen Fehler gar nicht so einfach fixen.
Es ist ja nicht so, als würde es jetzt einfach Windows neu starten
und dann ist gut.
Der Rechner ist ja wirklich geprickt.
Das muss man erst mal auf die Reihe kriegen.
Der ist ja kaputt.
Den kriegt ja keiner, der nicht ein bisschen Ahnung hat, wieder gefixt.
Der ist wirklich im Arsch.
Man darf nicht vergessen,
im Prinzip hat eine Anti-Viren-Software
mehr Schaden verursacht,
als alle Viren-Software, die sie verhindert hat,
zusammen hätten anrichten können.
Das muss man sich mal überlegen.
Anti-Virus verursacht mehr Schaden als Virus.
Lösung Arch-Linux.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich meine, ob es jetzt Arch-Linux ist,
aber Linux wäre in dem Fall...
Ohne dumme Third-Party-Kernel-Module, natürlich.
Ja, ich weiß, dass CloudStrike auch auf Linux läuft.
Glücklicherweise sind die meisten Leute nicht so dumm
und irgendwelche Third-Party-Kernel-Module,
die sich hot reloaden und updaten können,
überhaupt zu installieren.
Wie bootet man überhaupt in den abgesicherten Modus?
Ehrlich gesagt bin ich mir da mittlerweile gar nicht so sicher.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich einfach mit einem Live-Stick booten
und dort die betroffene Datei löschen danach.
Früher musste man ESC drücken oder F8, glaube ich.
Weiß nicht, was man heute drücken muss,
um in den Windows-Bootmanager zu kommen.
Ja, mit BitLocker dann nicht, ja.
Ja, ja, habe ich am Anfang des Streams gesagt.
Also prinzipiell kannst du Linux
mit kaputten Kernel-Modulen auch kaputt machen.
Glücklicherweise passiert das so gut wie nicht,
weil die Leute nicht so blöd sind,
irgendwelche Kernel-Module, Third-Party-Kernel-Module,
die sich auch noch live updaten und hot reloaden können,
irgendwie da einzubinden.
Und auf dem normalen Weg wäre das unter Linux halt nicht passiert.
Ja, gäbe es ein kaputtes Kernel-Update,
also das Kernel-Update wäre eh gekommen
über die offiziellen Paketquellen.
Dort hätten das die Leute schon mal getestet,
bevor sie überhaupt gepusht hätten.
Ich hätte es selbst testen können bei mir,
bevor ich das auf mein Live-System einspiele.
Deswegen hatten wahrscheinlich auch Linux-User
deutlich weniger Probleme.
Warum geht das mit BitLocker nicht?
Weil ich keine Ahnung habe, wie ich ein BitLocker-Volume
unter Linux anlocke.
Ob und wie das geht, keine Ahnung.
Kann Lux das? Okay.
Dislock.
Also anscheinend gibt es Leute, die haben das nachgebaut.
Ja, dann geht das auch unter Linux.
Wobei die ja nur Signaturen live updaten.
Na, anscheinend ja nicht.
Signaturen führen nicht zu einer Null-Pointer-Exception.
Die haben auch Logik geupdatet.
Das war auch das, was ich am Anfang des Streams gesagt habe.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum das beide so verbandelt ist.
Signaturen-Updates und Agent-Updates.
Beziehungsweise Logik-Updates.
Also was sie im Konkreten machen, habe ich jetzt
aus dem Buzzword-Bingo, auf dem ihre Website nicht erkennen können.
Wir hatten die Website ja heute Morgen auf.
Die machen ganz viele Buzzwords.
Die machen Threat-Craft, Machine Learning, Behavioral AI,
Custom LMMs, Foundry, Fusion, Generative Workflow,
ITDR, EDR, MDR, CDR, Intelligence, Manage Threat, Hunting.
Also was die wirklich machen, habe ich keine Ahnung.
Aber die machen Sachen, ja.
Das ist auch was, ja.
Okay Leute, ich muss das glaube ich nochmal sagen,
weil am Anfang des Streams waren nicht so viele Leute da.
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Normalerweise würde das gar nicht passieren,
wenn man das gescheit macht.
Wenn ihr eine Web-Anwendung betreibt,
gehen wir mal von was Einfachem aus.
Wenn ihr eine Web-Anwendung betreibt
und ihr wollt sicherstellen, dass ein neues Update
möglichst wenig Auswirkungen auf eure Benutzer hat
und dementsprechend auch auf das Geldverdienen von euch,
dann macht ihr das normalerweise so.
Als allererstes deployt ihr mal nur bei euch.
Die neue Version.
Und guckt euch das an, wie sich das verhält, ja.
Ihr habt vielleicht ein paar Tester, die das sich regelmäßig angucken
und schon genau wissen, worauf sie achten müssen.
Ihr deployt das nur bei euch, guckt, ob alles funktioniert.
Okay. Wenn alles funktioniert, dann deployt ihr das.
Allerdings stellt ihr das in eurem Loadbalancer so ein,
dass nur 10% der User das neue Update bekommen.
So ein bisschen so, wie YouTube das auch macht.
YouTube macht es ein bisschen anders, aber von der Idee.
Also 10% der echten Live-User kriegen das Update.
Und dann guckt ihr mal, ob irgendwelche Error-Reports hochgehen.
Automatische oder Hotline-Anrufe, je nachdem, was es ist.
Guckt ihr, ob das hochgeht. Wartet mal eine halbe Stunde.
Wenn das nicht der Fall ist, dann rollt ihr das aus für 50% der Leute.
Wartet vielleicht noch ein paar Minuten, dann rollt ihr das für den Rest aus.
Hätte man das gemacht bei CrowdStrike, wäre das sofort aufgefallen.
Schon bevor eigentlich ein Deployment wäre das aufgefallen.
Wenn die das nämlich bei sich lokal selbst getestet hätten, gescheit.
Dann wäre das aufgefallen. So.
Ist es anscheinend nicht.
Beziehungsweise sie haben es wahrscheinlich nicht getestet.
Aber Viren-Signaturen hast du... Ja, habe ich auch was dazu gesagt.
Ich verstehe ja, dass man Viren-Signaturen möglichst schnell updaten möchte.
Kein Ding.
Dann sollten es aber auch nur Signatur-Updates sein, die man schnell updaten kann.
Und keine Binary-Logik-Updates für den Kernel-Treiber.
Dass das alles anscheinend in einem Update drin steckt, ist ja schon mal prinzipiell fragwürdig.
Früher hattest du eine Anti-Viren-Software, die hat zweimal am Tag ihre Signaturen geupdatet.
Aber an der Anti-Viren-Software ist nichts passiert.
Wäre das hier auch der Fall gewesen, wäre auch nichts passiert.
Ich verstehe, dass das bei diesem ganzen Shit, was das Ding hier macht,
vielleicht mit reinen Signatur-Updates nicht auskommt.
Das kann ich nachvollziehen, was auch immer hier eigentlich genau passiert.
Dass man da die ein oder anderen Updates braucht,
beispielsweise für die Verhaltenserkennung in der Sandbox und so, kann ich verstehen.
Dann ist aber wiederum die Frage, warum das Bestandteil
des normalen Anwendungs-Execution-Paths von deinem Kernel-Modul ist.
Das ist auch schon mal Fail.
Also die Architektur ist für den Arsch und die Art und Weise, wie es ausgerollt wurde, ist für den Arsch.
Und selbst wenn man sagt, man möchte solche Updates möglichst live einspielen,
ich finde, eine Verzögerung von einer Viertelstunde ist durchaus okay.
Und mit einer Verzögerung von einer Viertelstunde hätte man das schon festgestellt.
Wenn die eine Testumgebung hätten, was sie anscheinend nicht hatten.
Spannend, wie sie sich dazu äußern.
Ja, also das ist an vielen Stellen verkackt worden.
Ach ja, und jetzt, ich habe es am Anfang ja schon erzählt,
und jetzt der Plot-Twist.
Was meint ihr, wer am Freitagmorgen Crowdstrike-Aktien gekauft hat?
Zwei Stück, für knapp 500 Euro.
Ich habe zwei Stück gekauft, einfach nur just for fun.
Und das liegt daran, ich weiß, dass ich es schon gesagt habe, aber die Hälfte war irgendwie noch nicht da.
Und das liegt daran, weil ich kein Vertrauen in die IT-Entscheider dieser Welt habe
und ich damit rechne, dass das einfach nach einer Woche wieder vergessen ist
und das Ding wieder bei 350 Euro landet.
Man könnte jetzt natürlich sagen, Max, wenn du da so großes Vertrauen drin hast,
dass das passieren wird, warum hast du nicht gleich 50.000 Euro ausgegeben?
So sehr Vertrauen habe ich da nicht drin, dass das stimmt, was ich sage.
Ich meine, ich habe, selbst wenn ich die jetzt wieder verkaufen würde, hätte ich schon 60 Euro.
Ja. Ja gut, bei Mac-F, bei denen wundert mich ja nichts mehr.
Ja, ist es irgendwie schon, ja. Wenn du es so willst.
Ich meine, Flughäfen, Krankenhäuser, alles Mögliche.
Mich würde nicht wundern, wenn auch die ein oder anderen militärischen Sachen betroffen waren,
von denen man jetzt nichts weiß.
Klar, könnte man sicherlich so definieren, ja. Nice.
Ja, mit Linux wäre das auch nicht passiert. Ich weiß, dass es unter Linux passieren könnte,
aber keiner ist so bescheuert.
Hat das so im Einsatz? Ja. Ich denke schon.
Allein schon, weil das bei den Amis ist. Die werden das erst mal auf 30 Trillionen verklagt. Easy Money.
Die funktionieren ja auch noch mit Windows 3.11.
Ich gehe auch davon aus, dass sie bestimmt irgendwelche super-spezialen AGBs haben.
Aber trotzdem werden die erst mal verklagt, as fuck, und dann ist...
Ja, da kommt es dann drauf an, was rauskommt.
So, aber jetzt gucken wir uns mal das FireShip-Video dazu an.
War das eigentlich Fake, dieses Bild auf Twitter, was man gesehen hat,
wo die ganze Stadionbeleuchtung ein einziger Plus-Screen war?
Warum auf YouTube nichts mehr passiert? Ich bin gerade...
Weil ich gerade nicht in der Stimmung bin, YouTube-Videos zu machen.
Das heißt jetzt nicht, dass irgendwas Schlimmes ist, aber ich bin gerade irgendwie nicht in der...
Nicht die Muße, YouTube-Videos zu machen.
Aber es ist nichts Schlimmes.
Ja, das ist genau das, was ich auch gerade meinte.
Die haben mehr Schaden verursacht als jeder Virus.
Es ist der 19. Juli 2024, und ihr schaut den Code-Reporter.
Die Europäische Union ist in Panik-Mode, weil alle Werk-Computer zerbrochen sind.
Das bedeutet, dass die Hamsters nicht mehr die Räder drehen können.
Ein riesiges Anzahl von Fortune-500-Firmen nutzen CrowdStrike für die Cyber-Sicherheit.
Es hat über 500 Kunden auf der Fortune-1000-Liste.
Sein Hauptprodukt ist Falcon, ein Tool, das End-Point-Protektion bietet,
mit Artifizier-Intelligenz und Analyse, um in der realen Zeit Schaden zu entdecken.
Hauptsache möglichst viele Buzzwords. Wir haben es ja auch schon auf der Homepage gerade gesehen.
Es wurde öffentlich getradet, und es ist auf dem Niveau,
und für einen guten Grund, weil jeder sie verurteilt hat,
dass Windows das Bluescreen des Todes erzeugt hat.
Glücklicherweise sind die MacOS-User und die Linux-Chabs unabhängig.
Um zu verstehen, warum, müssen wir erst einmal verstehen,
wie CloudStrikes Falcon-Sensor eigentlich funktioniert.
Es wird wie regelmäßiges Software installiert,
aber integriert sich mit dem funktionierenden System auf einem hohen Niveau,
oft mit Kern-Mode-Drohungen, und sitzt im Hintergrund,
um Anomalien zu beantworten.
Es sammelt Telemetrie-Daten, produziert Berichte,
und bietet viele andere unverständliche Technologien,
um Multimillionen-Dollar-Unterprise-Kontrakte zu ermöglichen.
Aber die Grundlage ist, dass es dritte-Party-Software ist,
das im kritischen Weg eines Computers sitzt,
was bedeutet, dass, wenn es verfehlt wird,
der gesamte Computer verfehlt werden könnte.
Ich habe ein 3rd-Party-Kernel-Modul installiert,
und zwar für Video,
dass man seinen eigenen Desktop quasi in Linux
als Kamera in OBS verwenden kann.
Also, nee, das war jetzt falsch ausgedrückt.
Also, dass du, umgedreht,
dass du dein OBS-Output als quasi Fake-Kamera
benutzen kannst in anderen Programmen.
So rum ist das richtig.
Sprich, das, was du in OBS siehst,
können andere Programme abgreifen,
indem sie denken, quasi,
dein OBS wäre eine USB-Webcam.
Das ist ein Video von Linux-Kernel-Modul.
Das habe ich installiert, ansonsten keine 3rd-Party.
Kernel-Modul, das ist ein Plugin im Endeffekt.
Stell dir das als Plugin vor.
Das ist nichts, was der Kernel von Haus aus mitbringt,
aber du hast einen Plugin-Loader im Endeffekt,
wo du deine eigenen Sachen mitladen und ausführen kannst.
Die laufen dann aber quasi auch im Kontext von deinem Kernel.
Und wenn die crashen, crasht halt deine ganze Kiste.
Vor MWare, nee, vor MWare-Module habe ich keine.
Nein, nee, nee, unter Linux ist...
Das ist das auch ein Kernel-Modul.
Aber das installiert keiner unter Linux,
der noch bei Verstand ist.
Oh mein Gott, ist das schlecht?
Es ist nicht nur ein normaler Outage,
sondern jeder effektive Computer muss in Fail-Mode gebootet werden.
Genau, das ist das Problem.
Es ist nicht einfach nur ein Reboot, es ist wirklich geprickt, das Ding.
Und die meisten Mitarbeiter haben keine Möglichkeit, das selbst zu machen.
Das bedeutet, dass die IT-Menschen heute wirklich beschäftigt werden.
Es ist das IT-Menschen-Äquivalent von einem Arzt in der Weltkrieg.
Die Konsequenzen sind wahr.
Die London Stock Exchange wurde zerstört.
Die meisten indischen Flughafen gingen runter,
aber es gibt noch andere Probleme.
Das Bild meinte ich vorhin übrigens.
Ist das Fake oder ist das wirklich echt?
Das ist schwer zu sagen, auch weil es so ein Low-Pixel-Bild ist.
Ich würde sagen, es ist Fake.
Ich hätte auch gedacht, es ist Fake, aber...
Weiß ich.
Zu Cloudstrikes Kredit,
sie waren schnell darauf eingewiesen,
dass es kein Sicherheits-Infektion oder Cyber-Attack ist,
und haben es so erklärt.
Hey, hör auf.
Äh...
Wir sind verdammt verrückt.
Aber sie waren schnell darauf eingewiesen.
Und die Lösung ist wirklich einfach.
All you have to do,
is to detach the operating system disk,
create a snapshot or backup of the disk,
mount a volume to a new virtual server,
navigate to the WinDir-Drivers directory,
locate the file C000000291.sys and delete it,
detach the volume from the new virtual server,
then reattach the fixed volume to the impacted virtual server.
Piece of cake, but option two is to go to Home Depot and buy a sledgehammer,
Option two is Windows neu installieren, easy.
then use it to uninstall Microsoft Windows
and switch to Linux.
I do feel really bad for the programmer who updated this driver, though,
because the tech lead is about to run git blame
and blame them for this whole mess.
Not only is this person about to get fired,
but they also have blood on their hands
for shutting down the hospitals,
transportation networks and Arby's family restaurants
that we need to survive.
If you're that guy and you're watching this,
don't feel too bad, though.
What we have here is a situation
where the cure is more harmful than the disease.
Public megacorporations are under a ton of pressure
to secure their computer systems
and they're constantly audited by third parties.
A company like Macy's isn't going to go out
and hire a team of 100 cybersecurity weirdos,
instead they'll pay a company like Cloud Strike
a few million dollars a year
to figure out cybersecurity for them,
giving them someone else to blame
when their system gets hacked.
What everyone failed to realize, though,
is that...
Da hat er recht.
Das ist ja auch eines der Punkte
dieser ganzen Support-Verträge
und das muss ein supportedes System sein,
alles Mögliche.
Ein Großteil dieser ganzen Geschichten
ist nicht wirklich, weil man ernsthaft denkt,
dass das irgendwie Fehler vermeiden würde
oder weil das irgendwie dazu führen würde,
dass das Ganze besser läuft.
Großteil dieser ganzen Support-Geschichten
und Audit-Sachen ist, dass man sagen kann,
man ist nicht selbst dran schuld,
sondern kann auf jemand anderes zeigen.
Das ist Fireship. Such Fireship auf YouTube.
Das letzte Video von Fireship, ja.
And I will see you in the next one.
Okay, im Prinzip das,
was wir uns schon gedacht haben im Vorfeld,
aber auf Fireship-Videos,
da macht die Dinge immer echt nice.
Pog!
Ich dachte, man sieht jetzt hier die Weep-CLI.
Was ist denn mit dem los?
Die meisten Katzen-Videos werden bessern
ohne Herrchen-Kommentare.
So.
Aber dann als Nächstes.
Was verdient eigentlich...
Warum hat der so schlechte Bewertung?
Was ist denn mit dem los?
Bestimmt, weil er keine ETFs verkauft
und die Leute von Finanzen-Reddits geraged haben
und das Video runtergevotet.
Echt jetzt? Wirklich?
Das habe ich jetzt gerade so geraten.
Ist das echt so?
Das hätte ich mir fast so gedacht.
Ja, gut.
Irgendwelche Vermögensberater,
die beraten nicht, wie du Vermögen bekommst,
sondern eher, wie man deins zu ihnen bekommt.
Ja, das kennen wir.
Das haben wir sogar schon im Stream zusammen geguckt hier.
Bit locker.
Vier-Tage-Woche.
Sollte jeder machen.
Das gucken wir jetzt.
Immer sehr entspannend.
Okay.
Easy.
Einschlaf-Stream wieder.
Ich müsste mein Lego-Technik-Kram auch noch irgendwo haben.
Als ich klein war, habe ich so viel Lego-Technik gebaut.
Das habe ich nicht weggeschmissen.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich noch auf dem Dachboden.
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich hoffnungslos outdated.
Wahrscheinlich habe ich irgendwelche ultra-wertvollen Teile oder so.
Musst du mal zum Held der Steine gehen?
Ja, der ist ja irgendwo am Südbahnhof.
Den habe ich mal random gesehen.
In Frankfurt am Südbahnhof, auf dem Weg zum Südbahnhof.
Was ist das für ein Super?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Ah, da ist so ein... Okay, jetzt.
Jetzt checke ich, wie das funktioniert.
Jetzt checke ich wieder nicht, wie es funktioniert.
Das geht aber noch advancer.
Weil diese Videos eskalieren immer voll.
Das fängt immer simpel an.
Am Ende baust du dann quasi irgendwie so einen halben Turm mit.
Die Elektromotoren sind zu teuer.
Kann man das nicht theoretisch mit irgendwelchen x-beliebigen anderen Motoren machen?
Muss es echt ein Lego-Motor sein?
Andere Motoren haben sogar noch ein bisschen mehr Power.
Oh, jetzt wird es advanced, ja.
So weit, so gut. So wird das Hedge auch noch hingekriegt.
Gibt alternative Hersteller von solchen Motoren?
Ja, auf AliExpress wahrscheinlich.
Weil die keine Angst haben,
verklagt zu werden.
Ein Parallelogramm-Lift.
Obviously. QuickMuffs.
Oh, das ist...
Das ist pfeifettes Ding.
Da wäre ich jetzt schon wieder nicht drauf gekommen.
Was? Okay, das ist Six Head Time.
So was habe ich aber noch nie gesehen in echt.
Gibt es so was?
Ja gut, das kenne ich. Das ist so ein normales Gerüst halt.
Die haben so ein Ding.
So ein Hebe-Ding.
So ein Teil hatten die auch, die bei mir die Klimaanlage an die Wand gebastelt haben.
Die hatten auch so ein Teil.
Ein Scheren-Lift. Aha.
Also ich kann mich noch daran erinnern.
Früher, als ich Lego-Technik-Krams gebastelt habe, ich habe ja
quasi mir die Sets damals gekauft, habe dann einmal das Ding gebaut, was drin ist
und danach eigenen Kram damit gebastelt.
Bei Lego war eindeutig der Weg das Ziel, ja.
Du hast es gebaut und hast dich mega gefreut, wenn es funktioniert hat.
Dann hast du dir das ein bisschen angeguckt und hast dir gedacht Okay, jetzt baue ich was Neues.
Also ich habe die Teile nie lange in der...
in der finalen Form gelassen.
Wenn es fertig war, wurde es auseinander gebaut und was Neues.
Oh, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Ich hatte so ein komisches Schiff mal gekauft.
Da war so ein Schiff und ein Bagger
mit Pneumatik dabei, wo man dann auch so Pumpen mit so einer Pumpe und so dabei.
Und später konnte man die Pumpe auch in den Motor reinmachen.
Das war richtig advances Zeug.
Ich habe dann immer Sachen gebaut, die konnte das so gerade heben.
Und irgendwann, das war so richtig mind blown.
Irgendwann hat mein Opa mir gezeigt, dass wenn man relativ sicher, dass mein Opa mir
das gezeigt hat, dass ich da nicht selbst drauf gekommen bin,
dass wenn man ein kleines Zahnrad an den Motor macht.
Und dann von dem kleinen Zahnrad auf ein
großes Zahnrad geht, dass dann der Motor quasi mehr Kraft hat.
Der falsche Ausdruck wahrscheinlich dafür ist.
Es geht ja auch alles langsamer.
Aber.
Das war so was wie eine Übersetzung machen kann, das wusste ich damals gar nicht.
Hat mir mein Opa gezeigt.
Das war so richtig mind blown Moment, dass man damit dann auch Sachen bewegen konnte,
die die man vorher nicht bewegen konnte.
Mein Opa war was, was, was, was war man?
Ich glaube, Feinmechaniker oder sowas.
Was war man denn, wenn man in der Fabrik
gearbeitet hat und Maschinen und so Elektronik an Maschinen gemacht hat?
Also Feinmechaniker oder sowas war das, glaube ich.
Mechatroniker und so gab es ja damals nicht.
Ich glaube, Feinmechaniker war mein Opa.
Damals gab es das noch nicht.
Ich glaube, Feinmechaniker.
Und der hat richtig, ne Elektriker war er nicht.
Der hat richtig Ahnung gehabt von so Oldschool
Elektromaschinen Kram.
Der hat ja auch den Fahrstuhl hier im Haus selbst gebaut.
Diesen Fahrstuhl hier.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das noch findet irgendwo.
Hallo Leute, hier ist einer der Feinmechaniker.
Boah, still, guck mal.
Ja, da ist die Treppe schon.
Wo ist sie? Hallo?
Wo ist der Fahrstuhl hier?
Irgendwelchen Gründen?
Ja, jetzt sieht man den Fahrstuhl.
Ja, hier ist der Fahrstuhl.
Guck, beste Kameraführung ever.
Ohne, ohne Anti-Wackel und mit 30 FPS damals noch.
Ja, guck, da ist der Fahrstuhl.
Den hat der Opa selbst gebaut.
Richtig high IQ, oder?
Guckt euch das an.
Hat auch schon ein bisschen Dellen gehabt.
Und das war richtig, richtig advanced.
Wenn du das hier nicht richtig zugemacht hast, das hier,
dann hat das nicht ausgelöst und du konntest nicht fahren.
Du musstest tatsächlich die Schranke richtig zumachen, dass das funktioniert hat.
Okay, Fahrstuhl.
Hat er alles selbst gebaut.
Man darf nicht vergessen, das hat er irgendwie gebaut.
Keine Ahnung, 1948 oder so.
Das hat, das hat quasi ein halbes Jahrhundert.
Gehalten.
Und es funktioniert noch.
Das musst du auch erst mal hinkriegen, oder?
Irgendwo sieht man auch den Motor.
Ich glaube, ich zeige euch, ich glaube, ich zeige den Motor auch gleich.
Gut, das war halt, wo wir gerade den Dachboden umgebaut haben.
Ja, hier sieht man den Motor, guckt.
Und hier ist halt auch so ein bisschen Übersetzung dran.
Hier ist ein Motor drunter, das angetrieben hat, sprich das ganze hing die ganze Zeit an
mit diesen Stahlseilen.
Richtig, richtig nice.
Nein, was soll das?
Richtig nice, was er da gebaut hat.
Der war Feinmechaniker.
Ich habe kein Schwitzhandtuch.
Ich habe eine Klimaanlage.
Das ist besser als ein Handtuch.
Da schwitzt man nämlich gar nicht.
Und ich habe nicht so eine,
so eine komische Klimaanlage, die man da durchs Fenster machen muss oder so ein
Schrott, sondern wirklich eine richtig echte eingebaute Klimaanlage.
Also ich habe ein Außengerät an der Wand hängen und hier innen drin.
So ein jeweiliges Split-Ding, Innengerät.
Hast du noch mal Baldur's Gate 3 angefasst,
nachdem du das Spiel erst mal durchgespielt hast?
Ich habe Baldur's Gate 3 nie beendet.
Weil ich hatte mit der Akt 3 keinen Bock mehr.
Das lag daran, weil das Max Level nur 12 ist, unter anderem.
Richtig abgehoben, Klimaanlage.
Ich kann euch prädikten, die nächsten
Jahre über werden noch viel, viel mehr Leute Klimaanlagen sich einbauen.
Das ist in Deutschland nicht beliebt.
Aber es wird uns gar nichts anderes übrig bleiben.
Wenn es immer wärmer wird,
da wirst du im Klimaanlagen nicht drum rum kommen.
Es sei denn, du willst einfach immer schwitzen die ganze Zeit.
Es werden sich noch viel mehr Leute Klimaanlagen einbauen.
Ja, das ist natürlich problematisch.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, dass auch immer mehr Mietwohnungen das Ganze bekommen werden.
Allein schon, allein schon, dass es irgendwann mal
ein Verkaufswerk,
wie nennt man das?
Dass das ein Grund ist, warum sich Leute für was entscheiden, weil es Klimaanlagen gibt.
Wie ist das eigentlich?
Klima mit Mietwohnungen, Klimaanlagen einbauen.
Naja, einbauen so richtig, dass du das, dass du da jetzt irgendwelche Löcher in die
Wand baust, so kannst du nicht machen. Es gibt Klimaanlagen.
Die kannst du mittlerweile am Fensterbrett
befestigen draußen.
Da musst du nichts einbauen, was nichts
reverse zu bauen, baubar ist.
Das ist wahrscheinlich erlaubt.
Ansonsten ist natürlich Löcher in die Wand bauen nicht
erwünscht.
Naja, das weiß ich nicht.
Das kann durchaus sein, aber innen drinne ist es dann auf jeden Fall kälter.
Also ich denke, in Zukunft wird das zunehmen, dass wir auch in Deutschland immer mehr
Klimaanlagen haben. Ich meine,
wir bewegen uns.
Also von der durchschnittlichen Temperatur wird es immer mehr.
Und das ist ja sogar so weit, dass wir jetzt irgendwelche tropischen Fliegen und
Mücken und sowas haben, die hier überleben.
Warum nicht auch Klimaanlagen?
Also ich gehe davon aus, dass die nächsten
Jahre über sich immer mehr Leute in die Klimaanlage einbauen lassen.
Ist ja auch eine sinnvolle Geschichte.
Ich meine, wir müssen jetzt halt damit rechnen, dass es.
Im Sommer unerträglich warm ist und drumherum auch so warm, dass es abfuckt.
Und dann ist die Klimaanlage einbauen.
Das ist ja auch das naheliegendste, was man machen kann.
Das ändert zwar am weltweiten Klima und Problem nichts,
aber es ändert an meinem lokalen Problem in der Wohnung was.
Willst du damit sagen, dass du an den Klimawandel glaubst?
Ja, klar.
Es ist aber auch nur möglich, weil die Erde flach ist.
Sonst würde das Ganze auf der anderen Seite runterfallen.
Also das funktioniert gar nicht anders.
Kappa HD.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal die...
Die Lego-Fahrstühle fertig an.
Chat, was habt ihr denn für Schmerzen?
Haus aus Lehm.
Ja, das ist das wahrscheinlich wieder schwer im Kommen.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es vor der Haustür irgendwie
jetzt auf einmal 20 Grad wärmer wird, nur weil die Leute Klimaanlage haben.
Guckt euch das mal in asiatischen Ländern und den USA, wo es schon immer deutlich
wärmer ist, haben die Leute auch eine Klimaanlage, was funktioniert.
Und das Schöne ist, sobald man reingeht, ist schön kühl.
Ich meine, natürlich wäre es am besten, wenn
wir das Problem nicht hätten, dass man eine Klimaanlage bräuchte.
Aber da kannst du als Einzelner nur so viel dran ändern, wie du ändern kannst.
Ja, du wirst das nicht, du wirst das nicht aufhalten.
Und das Einzige, was du machen kannst, ist,
dass das für dich persönlich erträglich wird.
Was willst du machen?
Und ich sehe keinen Sinn darin, zu sagen,
für das Wohl der Menschheit verzichte ich auf eine Klimaanlage und schwitze.
Das können vielleicht manche Leute machen, die das so super
idealistisch sehen.
Aber da fährst du anderweitig sicherlich besser.
Dann bau dir lieber eine Klimaanlage ein
und versuch dich sonst halbwegs umweltfreundlich zu verhalten, anstatt
sonst Kacke zu machen und dann dafür auf die Klimaanlage zu verzichten.
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Das liegt aber zum größten Teil daran, weil das sehr teuer ist.
Und das teuer wäre gar nicht so das Problem.
Weil du schlicht und ergreifend
niemanden findest zurzeit.
Also ich wollte mich da mal ordentlich beraten lassen.
Alleine schon das dauert ewig.
Und das Nächste ist noch es ist es ist teuer.
Und wenn man sich das ausrechnet, ab und wie sich das Ganze lohnt,
das von meiner Lage auch nur so semi gut.
Ich kann beispielsweise nur sinnvoll auf
einer Dachhälfte das Ganze machen, auf der anderen Dachhälfte nicht.
Und wenn man sich das mal so grob
ausrechnet, gibt ja so Karten, wo man nachgucken kann.
So Sonneneinstrahlung und geschätzt und sonst was.
Dann ist die Frage, ob sich das überhaupt jemals lohnt.
Also aus dem aus der also aus dem.
Also aus dem Grund müsste ich es wahrscheinlich nicht machen.
Ja, also lohnt wird ja bedeuten.
So quasi habe ich jemals dadurch mehr
eingespart, bis es erneuert werden muss, als als alles bringt.
Und da bin ich mir bei meiner Sache nicht so wirklich sicher.
Aber.
Ich würde es gar nicht machen.
Also nicht machen, weil es sich nicht
lohnt, wenn sich das so plus minus null.
Alles, alles ausgeht.
Aber es ist einfach saumäßig teuer.
Und du findest niemand, der dir es macht aktuell.
So, das ist so mein mein Problem damit.
An sich würde ich es gerne machen.
Ich habe noch nicht mal einen Balkon.
Könnte ja, ich könnte vielleicht.
Selbst das selbst das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Das müsste ich dann vielleicht
irgendwie auf das Garagendach oder so machen.
Aber das Garagendach ist nicht in einer guten Position dafür.
Aber das Garagendach ist das einzige, wo ich selbst was machen könnte.
Ich habe keinen Balkon,
wo ich das hinhängen könnte.
Ich bräuchte irgendwas, was man an eine Fensterbank vielleicht machen kann.
Oder halt was, was man eben aufs Dach legen kann, aufs
aufs Garagendach.
Aber da ist die Einstrahlung wieder nicht so.
Es ist gar nicht so einfach.
Ich habe mir das vor einer Weile schon mal angeguckt.
Ich bin da noch zu keinem sinnvollen Schlusssage kommen.
Direkt danke für den Sub.
Das ist länger her.
Das war irgendwann 2012 oder so.
Ich habe so
ich habe das mal so ganz grob, grob mir das angeguckt.
So grob wie das geht.
Ich müsste über 20.000 € bezahlen, wenn es mal reicht.
Wahrscheinlich noch deutlich mehr,
um das bei mir auf dem Dach alles ordentlich ausrüsten zu lassen.
Weiß nicht, ob ich da Bock drauf habe.
Und ich muss doch erst mal irgendjemand finden.
Aber das ist tatsächlich keine schlechte Sache.
Gerade im Sommer mit einer Klimaanlage in Kombination ist wahrscheinlich gar nicht so
verkehrt.
Ich weiß bloß noch nicht genau, wo ich es hinmachen soll.
Oder wo ich das gescheit hinmachen könnte.
Also das Garagendach suckt.
Ja, das ist aber das einzige, wo ich selbst was machen könnte.
Ansonsten habe ich nix an der Wand, wo ich irgendwas dran machen kann.
Da müsste ich, müsste ich halt selbst irgendwie.
Ich kann aber, ich kann aber auch nicht in keine Ahnung dreieinhalb Meter Höhe da
kommen, da weiß ich nicht.
Ja, das ist alles die Frage, ob du das wieder drinne hast.
Und wie gesagt, meine Lage ist an sich eh schon nicht so optimal.
Ich kann es eh nur auf der einen Hälfte vom Dach machen.
Und da weiß ich nicht, ob das sich rechnet, bis es denn mal erneuert werden muss.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich würde es auch gar nicht machen, weil sich groß rechnet.
Aber wenn sich so gar nicht rechnet, plus super stressig ist und rumgezackert mit
Handwerkern und allem.
Dann ist halt die Frage, ob das den Aufwand wäre.
Das habe ich, habe ich.
Ich habe mir vor ein paar Jahren eine einbauen lassen.
Die kann kühlen, heizen, Polen vernichten, also Pollen,
Pollen vernichten,
einfach nur lüften.
Und ich glaube, Automatikmodus hat sie noch.
Pollen.
So.
Ich muss Lego Lego
Aufzüge fertig gucken.
Jetzt erst mal durch.
Kommt der Pneumatik Aufzugstelle ist okay.
Damit habe ich früher gerne rumgebastelt.
Ich mochte.
Ich hatte dann irgendwann auch so eine Mini Pumpe, die man an den Motor machen könnte.
Ja, genau.
Ich hatte so eine. Ich hatte eine Pumpe,
die war noch ein bisschen kleiner und die konnte man an den Motor machen.
Dann konnte der Motor quasi pumpen für einen.
So, und da hat mir dann mein Opa gezeigt, wenn man das dann noch in Kombination
macht mit einer Übersetzung, kleines Zahnrad auf großes Zahnrad,
dass er dann noch stärker pumpen kann, richtig high IQ.
Wäre es eine blöde Frage.
Wäre es nicht sinnvoller?
Ach nee, Moment.
Das Ganze geht nach oben.
Okay, nee, dann passt.
Man hätte es ja umgedreht machen können.
Man hätte ja auch hier unten die.
Das Pneumatik Ding anschließen können und den Fahrstuhl selbst hier oben dran machen.
Dann wäre der Fahrstuhl höher gegangen.
Ja, das hat mich auch immer fasziniert, als ich klein war.
Oh, jetzt wird es advanced mit Gurt oder mit Kette.
Besser gesagt, das hat was von so einem mittelalterlichen Festungstor Gewicht.
Stellt highly advanced.
Gibt das jetzt mit Magnet?
Okay, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt kommt ja fortschrittliche Kram.
Unsere IQ nicht mehr ausreicht für
Mr. Amec, danke für den Sub.
Ich habe immer noch keine Ahnung, was das gibt, wenn es fertig ist.
Der will das quasi durch die Wand hoch.
Okay, aber sowas baut in echt keiner, oder?
Das ist etwas zu unsafe.
Da springst du dann mal drinnen und dann fällt das Ding runter.
Wow, Alter.
Jetzt.
Jetzt setzt man hier ein Aus bei.
Jetzt weiß ich nicht, was das geben soll, wenn es fertig ist.
Kogas Time.
What the fuck?
Das so ein bisschen wie bei einem Riesenrad, oder?
Ein Manlift, ja.
Nicht MWD geeignet.
Ach, so ein Ding, wo er dann reinlaufen muss.
Das sieht sehr unsafe aus.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Also Chat, falls wir demnächst,
falls wir demnächst mal einen Aufzug bauen müssen.
Jetzt wissen wir, wie es geht.
Wer braucht das nicht?
Ab und zu mal Aufzug bauen.
Hat noch keinem geschadet, mal einen Aufzug zu bauen.
YouTube Empfehlungen sind auch wieder wild.
10 Times Engineer Fix IBMs Procken Power PC.
Ah ja, alles klar.
Stop Using Gits Dash.
Also bei diesen Videos, ja, denke ich mir immer so.
Was kommt denn als nächstes, wenn das alles durch ist?
Kommt dann Stop Using Git.
Nachdem wir jetzt alle Teile von Git aufgehört haben zu usen, dann irgendwann.
Aber eins muss man dem echt sagen.
Git hält sich erstaunlich lange.
Das taugt halt einfach.
Normalerweise bei JavaScript Frameworks wäre Git ein JavaScript Framework.
Da wäre schon, das wäre schon 20 mal die nächste Sau durchs Dorf getrieben worden.
Was kommt als nächstes?
Aber das Schöne ist, dass uns Git auch ein bisschen, auf jeden Fall noch ein
bisschen erhalten bleiben wird.
Und ich rechne auch nicht damit, dass es da in nächster Zeit irgendwas geben wird.
Weil das einfach viel zu etabliert hat.
Auch das ganze Ökosystem.
Guckt euch mal nur GitHub an.
Aber das heißt jetzt mal so, theoretisch
könnte GitHub ohne Probleme auch andere Source Verwaltungssysteme anbieten.
Ich bilde mir sogar ein, dass GitHub mal ursprünglich sogar noch mehr konnte als Git.
Kann auch nicht durcheinander bringen und GitLab.
Das war.
Aber macht halt keiner mehr.
Wir haben auf der Arbeit ein.
Hey, diese, diese, diese Videos sind blöd.
Diese gucken wir jetzt nicht.
Diese Don't use Git Stash und irgendwie
letztens, letztens hat auch einer erzählt Don't use Git Pull und was auch immer.
Du kannst mittlerweile auf Git eh alles auf drei verschiedene Arten machen.
Und ich bin da auch nicht hundertprozentig up to date.
Ja, ich verwende auch immer noch Git Checkout anstatt Git Switch und solche Geschichten.
Kein Katz.
Leute, ich muss aufs Klo.
Übelst Pepo Pupu Time jetzt.
Ganz das vier Tage Video.
Was denn? Vier Tage Woche.
Ich arbeite seit über zehn Jahren nur vier Tage Woche.
Also beste.
Oh nee, das ist das.
Das finde ich, finde ich super nervig.
Diese, diese, dieses Format.
Da können die Leute nie richtig ihre Sachen ausführen.
Und da kommt das finde ich, das finde ich zu stressig.
Zum angucken.
Ist das nicht auch dieses Video Format
gewesen, wo der eine Arzt und diese Body Positivity Expertin sich gestritten haben,
der gesagt hat Ja, aber es ist erwiesen, dass Leute, die zu dick sind, öfters
Diabetes haben und die hat gesagt Nein, das kannst du so gar nicht sagen.
Doch, aber das ist statistisch belegt.
Ja, das sagst du. Das war doch das, oder?
Da habe ich mir auch nur an den Kopf gegriffen.
Am Ende kommt nie was bei raus.
Na gut, wo kommt schon was wirklich bei raus?
Ja.
Ich kann dir sagen, wo was bei rauskommt.
Wenn ich jetzt mal endlich aufs Klo gehe, dann kommt was bei raus.
Slim Beats, danke für den Sub.
Ich überlege gerade.
Ja, da käme auch was raus.
Ich überlege gerade, ob wir nachher noch ein bisschen C++ programmieren sollten im Stream.
Ich habe ja gesagt, ich wollte mal ausprobieren.
Dieses Async Request Feature vom neuen ESP-EDF Webserver.
Und das müssen wir in C++ machen.
Sonst kann man nicht drum herum.
Oder oder wir gucken uns.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Stream Themen. Wir haben sehr viel.
Das haben wir.
Das haben wir probiert. Das funktioniert immer noch nicht richtig.
Wayland in der VM.
Ich gehe jetzt erst mal was.
Ich gehe erst mal aufs Klo und dann gehe ich was essen.
Aber schon ein bisschen früher Schluss Chat.
Vielleicht basteln wir.
Haben wir uns eigentlich schon mal.
Das ist irgendwas mit Web Assembly, oder?
Ach, ist das diese Geschichte mit man kann Web Assembly auch auf dem Server laufen lassen?
Nee, haben wir uns noch nicht angeguckt.
Kann auch sein.
Ich habe schon ein paar Mal gesagt, wir gucken uns später was an und ich bin da nicht angekommen.
Schauen wir mal.
Ich glaube, wir bauen ein bisschen C++ Webserver.
Das wird wieder grausam.
Kann ich wieder drüber ragen, wie sehr das suckt.
Und ich hoffe, hoffe, das funktioniert dann auch.
Bis später.
Macht's gut. Muss erst mal wohin.
Bis dann. See you.